we have an important preface an
important caveat
an important disclaimer before we get
started and here it is
provided from my lovely lawyers here we
go
i am not an investment advisor all
opinions are mine alone there are risks
involved in placing any investment in
securities or in bitcoin or in
cryptocurrencies or in anything
none of the information presented today
or really anytime since you might be
listening to this anytime is intended to
form the basis for any offer or
recommendation or have any regard to the
investment objectives financial
situation
or needs of any specific person that
includes you my dear listener
so everything you're going to hear is
for informational entertainment
purposes only and with that said please
enjoy
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than 10 years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula
on the market it has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i
focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer on top of their all-in-one
formula
which is a free vitamin d supplement and
five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us
are deficient in vitamin d i found that
true for myself which is usually
produced in our bodies from sun exposure
so
adding a vitamin d supplement to your
daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support support your
immunity
gut health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
subscription again
that's athleticgreens.com
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything
seem to stem from good sleep so i've
tried a lot
to optimize and i've tried pills and
potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and for the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight lux mattress i also have one in
the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free
they'll even pick it up from you if you
don't love it and now my dear listeners
helix is offering up to two hundred
dollars off of all mattress orders
and two free pillows at helixsleep.com
tim these are not cheap pillows either
so getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h e l i x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal question now
what is
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show i'm
going to keep my preamble short because
we are going to run out of time well
before we run out of
subject matter with today's guest bology
srinivasan and i'm sure that that
pronunciation could be improved
at bala gs that's b a l a g
it's not a g it's a j i s is an angel
investor and entrepreneur formerly the
cto of coinbase and general partner at
andreessen horowitz he was also the
co-founder of earn.com acquired by
coinbase
council that's with a syl acquired by
myriad
teleport acquired by topia topia perhaps
and coincenter he has been named to the
mit technology reviews innovators under
35 that was in 2013
is the recipient of a wall street
journal innovation award
many others and holds a bs ms phd in
electrical engineering and
ms and chemical engineering all from
stanford university biology also teaches
the occasional class at stanford
including
an online mooc m-o-o-c that's massive
open online course in 2013 which reached
as i understand it more than 250 000
students
worldwide you can find them on twitter
at balaji s
i'll get it right this time with j b a l
a j
i s and you can find much more about him
on his website ball gs
dot com ball g thanks for coming on the
show
great to be here tim and i thought we
would start
with a number and that number is 1729
and as i understand it that's not in
reference to a date
but you use that number quite a bit
could you please provide a bit of
context
for how you've used that number and why
you've used that number sure
so i'm actually going to be launching
something
at that domain probably by the time this
podcast is published hopefully
so that's a domain 1729.com
what does it refer to it's not a year
it's the first number that's the sum of
two cubes in two different ways
and what that refers to is basically the
ramanujan number
you know so srinivasa ramanujan was
india's greatest mathematician
and kind of like india's einstein but
has kind of a romantic story
in the sense that you know he was
extremely poor
and wrote these letters to
mathematicians around the world he had
just
self-taught math from a textbook he
wrote these letters to mathematicians
around the world
and most of them ignored him just
thought he was a crank and one guy
brought him out to england this guy g.h
hardy
and we thought this guy has to be a
genius because no one would make up
these equations
and so then ramanujan began a rampage
through
mathematics and you know has people
still
to this day going through like a page of
his notebooks
for an entire mathematical journal issue
because he just wrote down all these
results that
were true but didn't provide the proof
you're just into it the result so where
does 1729 come from 1729
well unfortunately ramanujan died very
young very very young
from um people think it's because he was
away from his food and the warm weather
of india and so on but
basically on his deathbed hardy came in
to try to cheer him up
he said you know ramanujan i came in on
a taxi
and the license plate it's very boring
it's 1729 and on his deathbed
ranjan still had the wit and faculty to
say oh that's not boring it's the summit
first number
some two cubes in two different ways
because he's on a first name basis with
every number
and that's that's kind of the legend of
ramanujan and so if you've ever seen
goodwill hunting
i have yeah so goodwill hunting was kind
of based on that so was there's actually
a recent
there's a book that was turned into a
movie called the man who infinity it's a
very fun movie to watch i mean it's it's
engaging
i don't know how factually accurate it
is but there's pieces actually the
numbers in there and so on
but to me you know for many years
actually before
joining anderson horowitz what i was
gonna do is turn
the mooc course that i had done in 2013
into
like a global talent search because just
like
you have the hubble telescope looking
for dark matter around the universe
i thought of the mobile telescope the
telescope provided to us by mobile
could help us find the dark talent in
the global south
and you know the undiscovered talent and
basically
you know that's not just the global
south that's eastern europe that's
russia
that's all the former soviet countries
that's basically the
the world that all these people who
didn't have a chance
and i think of that as something that
i've wanted to do for a very long time
that's what i was going to do prior to
joining asics and z for a bunch of
reasons
you know i joined a6 and said in 2013
and i'm kind of coming back to the path
not traveled and doing this
global talent search and the idea is
that basically
we who have been fortunate enough to
have some resources or winnings we can
offer a hand up
to all these people bring them into the
global economy
level them up give them what we know in
terms of education or teaching or what
have you and all this stuff can be
delivered
i know it sounds like a cliche but at
scale over the internet right you
produce it once and you can replicate
across
millions of people so this is what i'm
what i'm doing next and
hopefully by the time the podcast comes
out this will be this will be live
knock on wood okay amazing so there are
these
seeming pillars of of influence
pillar may be too strong a word and i i
think we'll want to explore
a few of those including lee kuan yew
perhaps sure and we'll get to that for
people who don't know who that is we'll
we'll explain
because good god i mean what
what a figure and what an influence
before we move it further ahead what was
the subject matter
and the intent behind the mooc that you
taught
the subject matter it was the title was
startup engineering
and the concept was that it was
basically the class
that i wish i had had before doing my
first startup
and so it's kind of like a time capsule
back
to somebody who was into math or into
just technology in general but was just
completely naive about
how to actually run a business or
anything like that when doing my first
startup i actually
this is a first approximation but i
thought that the primary difficulty
would be
calculating difficult integrals and i
was like okay that's that's the hard
part and everything else is kind of kind
of basic whatever we can knock that out
before breakfast
uh and of course that's not the case as
often turns out
as often starts out that's right because
the thing is as you know i was a career
academic for many years
and in academia there is a high
premium placed on novelty of results
technical difficulty
and you know there's some some good
aspects of this you do
you know in math you learn how to think
rigorously and go
premise premise premise conclusion
really interrogate your results
there's seemingly obvious things that
aren't actually true mathematically
when you actually go and work them all
the way through famously like you know
the parallel postulate you know
euclid is not something you can just
take for granted you get different
geometries if you assume a different
condition there and you think rigorously
in academia
and then you think okay well that's
that's the entirety of the world it's
just technical difficulty
and it's not and so this course was
meant for teaching the philosophy
and all the nitty-gritty details to go
from a command line up to
a website with payments with javascript
and all that type stuff all the
because you learn computer science and
academia you don't really learn software
engineering
and there's a thousand details and how
that works which are useful to get
number one like
git and stuff like that and of course
the reason you don't learn those things
is they move fast you have to keep
updating it
so that was one piece and the second
piece was the philosophy of startups
meaning
what is the difference between a startup
versus small business or
why is this happening now there's piece
of recent history for example
don't the nsf aups i do not i'm not even
going to try to pretend
sure sure so national science foundation
had this thing called the acceptable use
policy in place
for many years and it prevented
commercial traffic on the internet
how about that so the dot-coms yeah the
dot-coms that we know and love were
actually not feasible
until i think about 1991 plus or minus
one or two years but i think it was 1991
they repealed the aup and the reason
people fought it they said there was
going to be
spam and porn and malware on this
commercial internet
and it's all going to be broken because
before that it was like an academic and
military internet everybody was sort of
a
quasi-trusted user on it you had to have
a mill or
edu domain right and then they're like
oh my god all these crazy people are
going to get on it's going to be
and you know what they were right all
that stuff did did happen
but yeah the benefit was worth it you
know the the downside was mitigated by
i think the upside um that was the birth
of the commercial internet
and that's something which most people
don't even know how that came about
it really was something where one rule
was
was holding back all this innovation
that's something that's made a deep
impression on me
so so like stuff like that was this kind
of stuff that i tried to convey in the
course alongside
the the nitty-gritty i think most of the
time that kind of stuff is not taught in
the same place from the same
person you know with one coloring the
other i think that's part of why the
course was popular
thank you it's a very comprehensive
answer i love comprehensive answers
sure i've been looking forward to this
conversation you're very good at
teasing out the the details and we may
end up teasing out the details on all
sorts of things in this conversation
including some of what one of our mutual
friends described as
one of several bologisms including the
line immutable currency infinite
frontier
or maybe frontiers and immortal life i'm
giving teasers to people so this is a
bit of a cheap
it's a bit of a cheap trick if you'll
excuse it another one
this is from we'll just say anonymous
although i think this sentiment
has been echoed by a few people i
chatted with which you may enjoy
which is something along the lines of a
quote
biology will end up on one side of a
firing squad but i'm not sure which side
and quit okay that's funny
i'm very peaceful i'm extremely peaceful
i just want i just want to put that out
there for the record go ahead
he's very peaceful and i i think that
part of what fascinates people
about you is how often they would
consider you prescient
and often that comes with a degree of
fear not of you but of the consequences
of you being right
and i'm thinking of for instance a quote
i think it was on january 8th
by the co-founder of rome research you
probably remember this one i think it's
at c-o-n-a-w
if i'm getting that right which was
something along the lines of
the most terrifying words in the english
language our biology was right
okay so i'm i'm planting those seeds
just because we're going to come back to
why some of the things you've predicted
accurately have in fact
been terrifying before we do that
a week we can if you want to say
something first we can we can certainly
we can dive into it
i will offer just a little bit of color
there which is
so what he's referring to is
specifically my predictions on
kavid and and the pandemic and so on but
then also more generally a bunch of
unheated
predictions or things that i've said and
that people would be like ah that'll
never happen and then this kind of
happens and so it's not so much that
it's always
bad predictions it's not always just
cassandra i like to think that i look
for
large deviations so that you can
actually get large upside as well as
large downside and so folks who
i think who followed me on investments
have done reasonably well but there's
both
we'll see there are there are both and
cassandra
for those wondering that is a
mythological reference correct
yes that's right is that the active
right the gift
given the gift of prophecy but with the
condition that no one would believe her
uh so we'll we will come back to some of
these
predictions and is it i want to say i
just heard you say kavid
most people would say kovid does it
matter is one correct and one not
i mean it's an acronym i have heard it
pronounced both ways covid or kova 19 or
coven
so i i have it yeah i'm gonna roll with
it we'll come back to that
now before we started recording and you
and i have chatted before we were
chatting but i thought it would be kind
of fun to kick the ball around
in the conversation about podcasts
because
you have opinions about the state of
media or mainstream media and perhaps
even the future of media which i'd love
to dig into at some point
but you had some perspectives on
the podcasting world
uh relative to perhaps other ecosystems
could you just
provide your first i don't say postulate
that's me trying to get fancy but no no
yeah all right please go ahead yeah so
basically let me give some definitions
first
so here's a one-liner that took me a
very long time to understand
so product is merit and distribution is
connections
for example a great blog post that
nobody sees
is a great product with terrible
distribution conversely
a really dumb article or whatever that
you know that is a piece of content
that is in a feed that is seen by
millions is a terrible product with
great distribution
and these are actually essentially
disjoint things
sometimes you can build products that
have distribution built in
like social networks or payment apps
where they're inherently viral
that's why people like them but most the
time these are disjoint things
and you have to put as much thought into
the distribution of the product you know
if you're selling
chairs or something like that it's not
enough to make a good chair you think
about okay
how do you get to walmart how do you get
to this distributor how do you get on
amazon all those kinds of things are
are critical parts of making it work and
peter thiel has this good line
which is that distribution is the thing
that just engineers don't get
part of the reason i think they don't
get it is that it's based on quote
connections
so it can't be just reduced to math or
at least parts of it can be
like your contribution margin and so on
but it is something where
a lot of it is quote networking or
knowing somebody
and people don't usually put thought
into this but when you walk into
a convenience store why are some energy
drinks pulled up all the way to the
front like five hour energy why is it in
the checkout aisle and why are others at
the back that is not an accident that's
a bunch of distribution
relationships and deals because people
are hyper conscious the store owner is
hyper conscious the fact that
being up front near the checkout is a
great spot to move inventory and that's
actually more valuable to be there than
at the back
it's a negotiation with them okay what's
my point point is
that i think an enormous amount of our
media ecosystem today is actually
something where the product is terrible
but they've got a lot of great legacy
distribution
so again a software analogy think about
um microsoft
or oracle oracle which makes a database
any
engineer you know is listening to this
the database is okay
but most people if you're starting from
scratch you'll use postgres
or an open source database or
combination of some kind
so oracle has kind of a bad product or a
declining product in many ways at least
relatively versus open source
competition but as great legacy
distribution because it's got its hooks
in all of these enterprises
the sales people know them it's also
hard to extract it
to pull it out how does that relate to
the podcasting thing
well if you think about distribution not
just for sales or
or for companies but for ideas media
creators can have
great content which is great product or
they can have lots of followers or lots
of influential followers for the
quantity and quality respectively of
their
distribution and podcasters when
two people tend to do a podcast together
they tend to have comparable
distribution
because they have comparable
distribution x hundred thousand y
hundred thousand or x million one
million followers
across platforms not any one platform
right that actually is it's almost like
the wild west where both people come to
a saloon armed
and our society lights us
[Laughter]
sounds like something that should be put
on the license plates here in texas go
ahead yeah
and what i think it's done is it's
changed the culture of podcasting
the thing is when everybody's kind of
comparable in distribution
the culture has changed to one of
politeness
back and forth give and take as well as
the long-form nature of it the contrast
to this is like a
journalist versus a subject podcasting
is peer-to-peer
journalist subject is hierarchical
there's a journalist a corporate
journalist an employee of a media
corporation and then there's the subject
as in
you know the subject under the
microscope or the subject and there's a
king in their subject
and that word or subject to that word
subject is such a revealing word it
gives away so much
the journal sent the subject under the
microscope and the thing is the general
subject relationship when the journalist
interviews the subject journals can edit
they can they can pull whatever quote
they want
and they have the distribution that the
subject doesn't they have millions of
folks who will read their thing
the subject can just squeak and can't
get a word out edgewise you know they
can they can yell all they want but it
doesn't do anything no one will listen
to them it's just boom
that's why people used to say never
argue with a man who buys ink by the
barrel
you're writing a little letter to the
editor and they've got you know they're
rolling off the printing presses right
it's as if you've got
millions of drones that you can just hit
enter and boom just push software
updates too
and this person can just talk to the
people around them because that's what
media is media scripts human beings
if code scripts machines media scripts
human beings even in ways
that we don't fully appreciate you know
that's why people spend so much in
advertising
you might think advertising doesn't
convince you of something but it just
sort of reminds
you that coca-cola exists and then
you're at the start you know maybe i'll
get a coke
that's how words are picked up that's
how vocabulary is picked up a small
example if i said
postulate like eight minutes ago or nine
minutes ago you might say postulate two
minutes ago right that's a small example
right that's not bad it's just
how we should think about it point being
that once we are
equal on distribution then we can
actually speak to each other as peers
and it's futile to try to argue with
someone
who has way more distribution in this
hostile you just need to build your own
distribution which is much more possible
in the internet age
i agree with that i agree with the if we
were to
put it in in delicate terms these
mutually assured destruction
element of civility i think there are
also a few other contributing factors
one is that many journalists working
under
a masthead have the
air cover right they have the air cover
of not only
the reputation whatever that might be it
doesn't need to be the most prestigious
publication but the
they have the reputational cover they
also have the insurance cover right the
errors and omission policies
in actual insurance those clauses within
actual insurance policies
and some degree of legal protection by
their employer
would be one another is that
very often podcasters
have experienced having their quotes
cherry-picked or have been on the
receiving end of
a hit piece and therefore
i think are just more sensitive to
inflicting that on other people
exactly empathetic yeah they're more
empathetic
and i would say that
you see that very clearly you see a
shift sometimes not always
in journalists and there are many
spectacular wonderful
diligent ethical journalists out there
some of them are very close friends of
mine
in those who are say tending towards
the kind of cynical cherry-picking side
once they launch this is how it usually
or often happens their own book
and now suddenly they are at the whim of
other media and other reviewers and
other
critics they really for the first time
sometimes get a large dose of their own
medicine
and often that can can stem the tide
a little bit i would say last not to
give podcasters too much ethical credit
although
i certainly some of them and many of
them are ethical i think that it's very
difficult to cherry pick
when you're interviewing in long form
not only that but both sides can very
easily record so
there are a lot of a lot of factors that
make it a
friendlier format although i will say i
have had
podcasts that are highly produced try to
pull a fast one
on me before and uh not that this is
terribly relevant but that was how i
learned to listen
and pay attention to my dog very closely
because it was one of the few times
that this woman walked in this is
pre-covered as many years ago
to interview me with a producer and so
on and my dog
growled the dog growled molly growled
and that almost never happens and i
apologized
for her growling and continued the
interview and very quickly realized that
i was being led into a trap
and i just i just stopped the interview
i said yeah i think that if this is how
you're going to approach it
we're done and it turns out if they're
on deadline
and they have a highly produced piece
and they have a lot of employees and
mouths to feed
that that is actually a reasonably
strong move
assuming you can afford to do it is just
to not play ball just to walk off the
field
and so a lot to be said about media
oh absolutely i mean the thing is
actually the non-answer
the ignore the block is
actually quite effective as an
individual and even more effective
if practiced by a large group of people
like there's the site blocknyt.com
that if you saw you know actually did
like quite well on twitter
and it's like a minor hit and i think
you're going to see much more of that
where essentially the issue is that
a journalist versus subject it's almost
like a traveling salesman
who goes town to town and runs a con on
this person and
the next person the next person there's
this great book called the journalist
and the murderer
that actually documents this have you
heard of this
no i have it but that's a hell of a
title it's actually in the modern
library's like i think top 100 books of
the 20th century
it's called journalism murder it's by a
former journalist
and essentially it talks about how
there's like this
really brutal killer and a journalist
who
interviewed that killer and then you
know published a story that was like a
huge misrepresentation and the
killer was like so mad they sued the
journalist and the jury actually ended
up sympathizing
with a murderer over the journalists
once they understood what the journal
said done
so it's a phenomenal book you should
read it actually you know i'm gonna i'm
just gonna
read you the opening of it because it's
so
good uh it's by janet malcolm of the new
yorker okay ready
famous opening every journalist who is
this is her quote okay it's not mine but
it's all right
every journalist who's not too stupid or
too full of himself to notice what is
going on knows that what he does is
morally indefensible
he is a kind of confidence man preying
on people's vanity ignorance or
loneliness
gaining their trust and betraying them
without remorse like the credulous widow
who wakes up one day
to find the charming young man and all
her savings gone so the consenting
subject of a piece of non-fiction
writing learns
when the article or book appears his
hard lesson
journalists justify their treachery in
various ways according to their
temperaments
the more pompous talk about freedom of
speech and the public's right to know
the least talented talk about art the
seamless murmur about earning a living
okay so i want to offer but by janet
malcolm
of the new yorker so i wanted to say
that's that's a journalist
on corporate journalists basically if
for those who want to
there are two sides to this coin and i
want to say for those who want to
further educate themselves
on the dark arts and those
gambits they might fall prey to there's
also a book called trust me i'm lying
by ryan holiday which covers a lot of
this including
the tactic of getting an email 20
minutes before a piece is going to be
published
asking for comment which of course is
intended to
not elicit any any comment or panic you
right
or other tricks you know i'm going to be
commenting on you whether
you provide a quote or not therefore you
should do a b
or c but that's a good book on some of
the dark arts and
don't lose your place i don't think you
will because you seldom do
but this also lends
all the more testament to those
journalists who can withstand and
methodically
counteract these powerful incentives and
motivations to
actually do good work
where they don't get sucked into this
this vortex
of perverse incentives so i i do want to
say that the people who are actually
able to stand in the eye of the
hurricane and do that
i give a tremendous amount of respect
because it's hard i
understand what you're saying i do think
that the structural incentives in the
profession now
are such that you've got someone who's
literally just swimming against the
stream
and i think actually part of the issue
is that it's a profession in the first
place
and what i mean by that is you know like
the the founding fathers
talked about how a standing military was
a bad thing
because you'd have this praetorian class
that was
armed to the teeth and there would be
again subjects
and that praetorian class was in drills
it had its own
esprit core its own sense itself and
would increasingly go contemptuous of
these civilians who they watched over
you know and that was a recipe for for
bad things so that's what they
preached against a standing military now
the u.s
basically didn't have a standing
military for a long time
until essentially the permanent wartime
mobilization of the 20th century
especially world war ii
you know before it was like you know the
ideal was to have citizen soldiers
like if you've seen the movie 300 where
all the athenians come out
and it's like you know i'm a potter and
i'm a baker or whatever and they
grab an axe and go to war but they're
not permanent
military now whether we can get
back to a standing military or rather
away from a standing military to a
citizen military
i think that's going to have to wait
till mid-century when it's all drones
at which point then it's all computer
programming and actually so that's
i know that's just a cast off for mark
so within the next 30 to 40 years once
we get to the sort of asymmetrical
warfare where the cost of offense is
much lower than the cost of defense with
armies of drones is that what you mean
yeah i think i think basically
sometime mid-century maybe more you know
if you followed the
just as a footnote on a footnote but the
armenia azerbaijan conflict right which
was heavy on drones you know that's a
glimpse of the future warfare you know
the
future's already here but it's not
evenly distributed kind of thing so
i i do think that eventually once you
get full automation of everything it'll
actually be
just drone on drone and then you know
people will surrender rather than
have the civilians killed it actually
might be more ethical in some way it'll
be obviously a transitional phase
the transitional phase of human versus
drone will sort of be like
early in world war one there are cavalry
charges versus
machine gun nests the calvary were just
kind of this outdated way of war that
quickly went away human versus drone
human versus robot will be like that i
think
and then people will quickly be like
okay i reach sneak robot versus robot
anyway so leaving the standing military
bit aside because i don't think that can
be solved
in the short term by analogy there's a
concept of standing media
a standing media is again like a
praetorium class or a select class a
quote elite
that among themselves practices certain
behaviors that
the average person can't and what's
interesting is ny mag
you know had this uh thing a few years
ago like the media on the media
and it was um let's see if i can find it
uh here is it this survey right okay i
was finding the exact thing
the media on the media july 24 2016 9 pm
one of the biggest things that they all
agreed on
is journalism's biggest blind spot it's
coverage is group think we draw from a
limited pool of people
who generally have a similar background
class or simply unable to see the
perspective of people who are not like
them
and tend to drive out those who don't
fit in now i actually understand this
coming from academia
i could see how that epistemic bubble
happens it's ironic that the people who
complain often most about filter bubbles
are actually complaining about the
plural
because there was just one filter bubble
that they controlled
and now they're annoyed that there's
more than one they've competing filter
bubbles competing filter bubbles exactly
so the way i kind of think about this is
the answer
is not reform the answer is not to
tell these professionals hey go in
journalism better
or hey you're doing a good job this
guy's doing a bad job i think that's
been tried for a very long time
i think the answer is radical
decentralization in several ways
one critical way is everyone a
journalist
so citizen journalism as opposed to
corporate journalism
so this way you don't have a media
corporation that's literally running
billboards
declaring itself to be truth incarnate
lest i exaggerate that's literally the
slogan of one large media company that
she'll go and name it runs a billboard
saying it's the truth
and yet these media companies are
basically the big ones are
nepotistic endeavors they're passed down
from father to son
they are everything that they castigate
technology for being
which it isn't you know they're these
kind of inbred sort of things right and
no one ever
points us out right no one points out
that the owners of these papers are
actually
like just literally father to son kind
of endeavors which is not happening in
tech right you don't get
father you people found their companies
in tech so the alternative to
you know like sort of this hereditary
dictatorship running these
media corporations is everybody writes
and you have local expertise you have
chemical engineers writing on chemical
engineering and you have
biologists writing about biology and you
have computer scientists writing about
computer science
and they do it as a duty not for profit
meaning it's actually the fact that
there is this
corporate business model there basically
currently incentivizes them to go for
popularity and the number of clicks as
opposed to
truth now you might say are you against
profit etc no i'm saying that the
citizens journalism part is one
important component let me give two or
three more
a second important component is
decentralized cryptographic truth
and this is a big concept i'm not sure
i'm going to be able to do it justice in
a few sentences but i'm going to try
which is to say it is now possible with
cryptocurrency
for a israeli and a palestinian
a chinese person a japanese person a
democrat and a republican to all agree
on the state of the bitcoin blockchain
regardless of your political views your
geography
people agree on how much bitcoin someone
has
okay globally this is an
incredible triumph because you know
a trillion dollars forget it i mean a
million dollars is the kind of thing
that people will
fight over and disagree on and so on
there's essentially no dispute
on who owns what btc and that's the kind
of thing that people tend to have large
disputes over a trillion dollars people
tend to fight over they tend to
try to fake history they train to forge
things all the type of stuff right
the point is that once you can develop
consensus algorithms that can get people
to agree on
what bitcoin someone had at what time
you can extend them as we're doing to
get people to agree on
what property somebody had at what time
so what stocks what bonds
what real estate with this with that
which is again another huge
component of the kinds of things people
fight about and then less obviously
you can extend that to what events
happened at what time
so what device recorded this temperature
in kansas on this date
or what hospital uploaded this medical
record
to the blockchain at this time or what
was the price
of this house that was sold in this area
or what crime was reported
by this victim or this police officer in
this area all of these feeds of data
right now that are happening
in these kind of disparate silos you put
them together into something i call the
ledger of record
which is a global feed of
cryptographically timestamped history
undeletable history and this it's kind
of like twitter in the sense of
when people are referencing whether
something happened they're like is that
tweet real
and you go to the permalink and you want
to see whether someone actually did
that's imperfect for many reasons one of
which is that twitter can man in the
middle it
another is that the person's account can
get hacked and they can post to someone
else has happened you know last summer
with cryptography with digital
signatures not going into all the
details
that offers not a perfect set of checks
but a much greater set of checks on this
becomes much harder to falsify history
you can't delete the tweets as twitter
can do
there's a lot of things that come into
it where that feed becomes incorruptible
it becomes an indelible ledger and it
becomes cryptographically validated
and so what i think in crypto this is
called crypto oracles the point being
that you're no longer relying on just
pure humans fallible humans to tell you
what is true
you rely on decentralized cryptographic
truth rather than corporate truth
and this is already the kind of thing
which is the input to smart contracts
handling millions of dollars
i think we're going to scale this out
over the next 10 years and this is
actually the alternative
to a few folks in brooklyn trying to
determine what is true for the entire
world which simply doesn't scale
not that it ever did but it's very
obvious that it doesn't all right let me
pause there a lot to digest there's more
i could say
that is a lot to digest so it'll be very
interesting to see
what happens to long-form journalism
that is pieces that would take
possibly weeks or months of time
dedicated time
to produce but putting a bookmark in
that we can always come back to it
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on fifty percent
five zero percent of your returns don't
miss out on the best days in the market
stay invested in a long-term automated
investment portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees
and lower your taxes takes about three
minutes to sign up and then wealthfront
will build you a globally diversified
portfolio of etfs based on your risk
appetite and manage it for you at an
incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay
on your investment gains their newest
service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today
at wealthfront.com tim
there are a few things that i would love
to get your
opinion on perspective on and i'll
give give kind of a preview of the two
one will be
current forms of self-defense whether
preemptive
or reactive while we're waiting for the
future to be evenly distributed
what can we do in the meantime to
protect ourselves
or counter punch if we're being
potentially mistreated by
members of the media that's one and then
after that i'm going to ask you about
for yourself keeping a ledger of
predictions much like you've recommended
people to write out the bull bear and
base case
of joining a company and then checking
themselves say a few years later
but let's first talk to any particular
strategies or tactics for
defending oneself exactly for
self-defense do you have any thoughts
there
sure so i i have several the first is
maybe
the least obvious which is you should
radically reduce your expenses if
possible
because financial independence is
upstream of individual independence
and ideological independence if you're
in lots of debt if you're not in debt
but you're just
spending every dollar you have because
you live in an expensive area
then you are extremely conformist
because oh my god you lose your job and
you have no savings and
you've got this high consumption and so
you just have to
stay in line for everything now if you
want to live like that
go ahead okay but if you don't the first
thing to understand i think is that
it's much easier to reduce your costs by
5x
than increase your top line by 5x it's
possible to do both
but it's almost deterministic to reduce
costs if you're willing to do it and how
do you do it
you go to nomadlist.com or teleport.org
and you do a spreadsheet and you
optimize your personal runway
and your personal runway is what it
sounds like this is a concept i
developed it's very obvious but just
extends constant corporate runway to
individuals
it's your savings divided by your burn
rate and here's the thing the moment
that you move to
let's say bali or some very inexpensive
locale
and start living like a grad student and
of course this is most applicable for
people
earlier in their life it's harder for
folks with families and what have you
right
so i recognize that but even then it can
be done there's a reddit group called
think
lean fire financial independence retire
early there's mr money mustaches folks
who do this kind of thing like household
budgeting but as an individual it's
actually relatively easy
we do now and this is actually even
easier in 2021 than it was when i first
started recommending this
you get a remote work job at a good tech
company
it could be any company of course but
you know let's just say you know tech is
it's because it pays well or whatever if
you can get it
but a remote work capable job you move
to the
cheapest place that you can tolerate
that's good and actually
there's actually some really great
places that are cheap and warm
especially now that remote is feasible i
mean basically all of laden and south
america if you have to be in an american
time zone for example
and big chunks of canada if you like the
cold you know and of course the midwest
and what have you there's
huge areas of the map that have opened
up thanks to remote and
if you do that and if you cut your
expenses 5x
now you go from just as a thought
experiment let's say you're making i
don't know 100 000 a year as an engineer
and before you're in san francisco and
you're burning like 90 000 of that a
year or something
that's actually not insane a lot of
people do exactly that right because the
rent is so high
now you go to some rural locale
or even overseas and now you're actually
only burning
let's say 50k a year 40k in tax or what
have you and then like
10 or 20k let's hit 60k okay 20k in
expenses because you just cut it all the
way down
well now every year that you work you
have basically built up because if your
income goes away your taxes away as well
every year that you work up if you're if
you're spending 20k a year you have 40k
in savings if you just do out the math
earn 100 spend 60 bank 40.
if your spending is 20 then you have two
years of runway personal runway added
for every year that you work there in
this simple toy example and that means
that you don't need to accept angel
financing you can sell finance
you can just for every year you work you
can take two years off it's
basically a way of getting personal
financial independence like a
deterministic path to doing it
now of course you're no stranger to this
you've been talking about this stuff
forever you know with the four-hour work
week
this is not it's not unusual for your
audience but i think that the
perhaps somewhat novel is connecting
this to ideological independence
because it means you can't be canceled
you know you can just write it out
like you know the square jaw chad yes
you know from you know the memes i'm
talking about no no i don't what is the
square john chad
okay okay this is very very online but
if you google the chad
yes it's like you know someone being
like oh my god i can't believe you
believe this or whatever and the guy's
like
yes and that he's just not backing down
at all just totally
firm square jawed chad
you never seen this no
no that's all right i didn't know who
taylor swift was until like four years
ago so i'm
i'm a little i'm a little sheltered it
would appear yeah it's like
it's like it comes from you know yes
chad know your meme here i'll send you
the
i'll send you the thing anyway i'll put
this in i'll put this in show notes for
for people right next to drone warfare i
bet 99
99 of your audience says i this is maybe
it's obscure maybe or maybe it's not i
don't know but
we'll have to see anyway point is how do
you
do the square jaw chad yes it means you
have to be able to
you know you're not backing down you
accept what consequences may come
because you have planned for the future
you know
conflict may come and you have
essentially banked up
and so so that's let's call that one
piece right financial independence
and it requires not to state the obvious
but it requires
or may not even require courage the less
fear you have right if courage is acting
in the face of fear
if you have minimized the risk or the
damage
of being cancelled or any type of media
retribution
you have less fear to overcome it just
makes it easier like you said to have
that ideological freedom
to hold the position that's right the
second thing is
if you read books like beautiful trouble
you know what that is i do not
okay so that's like uh i feel like i'll
be saying i don't and i do not a lot in
this conversation please continue
no no it's a so so beautiful trouble is
an awesome window into another world
which is it's sort of like you know how
it's it's a handbook for activists
and uh so you sort of learn when you
read it you'll be like whoa i recognize
that
from this event and i recognize that
from this event
and you start to realize actually how
much stuff you read
in the paper some part of it is sort of
from corporate pr
but another big chunk of it is from
activist pr for example
taking um a laser pointer-ish thing and
shining a logo onto the side of a
building there's various kinds of stunts
like this but the one that's relevant
here
is there's this concept called spectrum
of allies where
you've got people who are at let's say
there's five categories strongly
supportive
weakly supportive neutral mildly opposed
and strongly opposed
and your goal as an activist is to
recognize you can't just move people
from plus two to minus two right away
what you do is you try to find some
incident or thing
that is bad and then you go and you put
a microphone to everybody
and you force them to comment on this
person or the sense of like
can you excuse this horrible thing and
you try to force them from a
you know a plus one to a zero or
whatever right now
that is actually a very premeditated
thing
one way of visualizing it is it's an
attack on your social network
okay this is a premeditated thing it's
not like a organic thing
and it's a spectrum of allies and uh one
way of thinking about this is
you have a social network supply chain
okay so visualize yourself you're a node
at the center and you have
your employer let's say your ceo you
have your investors
you have your employees you have your
customers right there's all these nodes
around you i'm talking about from like a
text startup context but you can of
course generalize this to something else
and those nodes can be colored you know
let's say they're gray or blue or red
they can be colored according to their
ideology and
the most important thing about your
social network supply chain and this is
not obvious
it is what periodicals they read and
respect
because those periodicals have root
access to their brains
if a periodical suddenly says you know
let's say the wall street journal and
you've got a bunch of republicans
surrounding you for example right
the wall street journal suddenly says
you are bad all those people
who read and respect the wall street
journal will suddenly like zombie-like
turn their eyes glowing red and start
excommunicating you
or they'll move in the spectrum of
allies so the guy who is
on on the fence may quit the person
who's really strong
and strong supporter might move to what
the minimum contractual obligation is
and so the attack it's like a mortar
that lands in somebody's social network
neighborhood
that's that's what negative presses
negative press is an attack on your
social network
now how do you mitigate this well first
as i mentioned you are
you're like a quote sovereign individual
you're financially independent so if
people pull away it doesn't matter but
second and more important
you need to actually identify where
likely attacks are going to come from
and make sure you actually choose your
friends your employees
everything such that that's actually
robust to
foreseeable kinds of attacks right you
robustify your social network supply
chain
in the same way that a judicious
person who runs a manufacturing plant is
thinking okay
china has some supply chain risk you are
thinking okay that person
has social network supply chain risk i
think they would go south
in this event and then you might want to
get them off the board
or you might want to not hire them as an
employee
or having a contractor and that's
actually better for them as well
because they may or may not know it but
they're basically like the manchurian
kid
they've got like a remote chip in their
brain and there's like this
when when you're denounced okay
and now we have it actually relatively
good in
you know the west in you know the the
term canceled by the way it's actually
very juvenile it kind of comes from like
tv shows being canceled like canceled
cultures like teenagers complaining
about and this sort of
elliptical way of complaining about has
made its way up to 30 and 40 and 50
somethings discussing this topic
but the original term for being canceled
was being purged
that's what they called it in the soviet
union and the people's republic of china
and so on right
and it could well be said that in the
soviet union or the prc
an editorial was a prelude to an
extraditional execution
you wouldn't just you know quote get
canceled and lose your friends
you'd lose life liberty and or property
you'd be
shot or jailed or certainly expropriated
or
all of the above sent to a labor camp in
the cultural revolution
correct and the other nodes in your
social network might be as well
like if you were you know a member of a
family that had a
known capitalist rotor in china
not really very good it was possible
just like people come back from being
canceled
deng xiaoping was actually purged three
times his son was
thrown through a window and you know
like during the cultural revolution and
was in a wheelchair for the rest of his
life so i mean this is the kind of stuff
that happened in other countries
it got even more violent than it has so
far in the us
but we'll see what happens you know with
that anyway point is that you know so
that's a second mode of defense first is
personal financial independence and
second is collective independence
you want to really think through
who the nodes are that are associating
with you by the way one interesting
consequence of this if you flip it
around
is if you have a monochromatic supply
chain
there's basically nobody for example at
the new york times company who
reads and respects breitbart so
breitbart has zero effect on the new
york times company
no node there can be manchurian
candidate by them but the new york times
company
absolutely on if you go to breitbart's
like extended social network supply
chain
there's absolutely folks you know
whether it's ads or other kinds of
things that read and respect nyt
so a can publish article has no effect
on b but b
can publish it and it has an effect on a
another example is
if xinhua general daily and by the way
i'm not saying anything pro or con about
breitbart in my team just making an
observation a fact there another example
is
xinhua net you know in china the chinese
you know people's daily
uh if you're chinese and they denounce
you your whole social network supply
chain is like whoa the government just
announced this guy
you're in trouble if you're in the u.s
nobody even reads chinese or even cares
hey these guys are totalitarians who
cares you know at least that's that's
what folks
you'd be able to brush it off and so so
it's more than just quote red or blue or
whatever it's it is
there's other colors to it right
whatever you'd assign the color to the
ccp or what have you and so
you know another one might be if al
jazeera denounces you or russian state
media denounces you you've got
vulnerabilities to different kinds of
things if you were
a russian expatriate you might be much
more concerned
if you know rt suddenly started going
after you than if you were just
some random you know american or or even
a chinese person go ahead let me pause
there
well i was thinking we could i'd be
curious to hear
what else you have thought about for
yourself
in terms of of self-defense if there are
any
tactical recommendations and just also
to
come back to one of the examples you
gave
with reducing your expenses by 5x
would you not so it's a combination of
questions we can you can take them in
either order but if you were employed by
a tech company whether that's a google
facebook or otherwise
is that not a significant
vulnerability in the system while
financially if you maintain your job
you can withstand
say public denouncement or media
denouncement
but the company may not have the same
willingness absolutely absolutely so let
me get to point number three
so point number three is i gave a whole
series of talks on this and i've been
thinking about the technology for it as
well
something i call the pseudonymous
economy so
the thing is that real names weren't
built for the internet real names are
actually a technology in fact real names
are stolen base in many ways even the
term real name is the stolen base
it's better called a state name or a
social security name
because it's a global identifier it's an
identifier that anybody can type into
a database and pull up all kinds of
information on you and
this is something where historically
past cultures understood that giving out
someone's
real name was actually very bad you know
or knowing it you had power over that
person
the reason is that if you read read this
book seeing like a state
seeing like a state yeah seeing like a
state this is a great book
by yale university press that
essentially talks about how names were
developed to among other things simplify
the process of conscription
so rather than oh that guy over there
with brown hair which is an analog
identifier
that could refer to a bunch of folks
that was imprecise and said you'd say
john davison and that first name last
name was a
it's not perfect it's not quite as good
as a number but it's
a reasonably good digital identifier
where you could go down a list and cross
it off
and the thing is that would not just be
conscription but you couldn't have
even executed like leninist
redistribution of property very easily
without those lists it was all about the
list
literacy is what actually enabled a big
big chunk of that um you had lists of
names that's guy's rich that guy's not
rich take his property etc
so the the point being that the
alternative to real names or like a
single global identifier and everything
is pseudonyms search resistant
identities which people are already
using at large scale there's 400 million
pseudonyms you know or pseudonymous
users on reddit and by the way there's a
distinction between
anonymous pseudonymous and real name
anonymous is totally disposable
identifier that's like the culture of
4chan that actually is kind of a pit
pseudonymous like reddit is a persistent
pseudonym that accumulates reputation
but that is at a distance from your
global identifier
in general what i think is the you know
the piece of westfalia
at the end of our 30 years internet war
is going to be
hold on pause for definition if i could
click on
do you say westphalia yeah so from 1618
to 1648 protestants and catholics
slugged it out
over religion but also over power you
know who's going to rule the catholic
church you know or
or you know martin luther's guys the
disciples of protestants
very bloody war lots of killing and it
was basically centralization versus
decentralization you know among earth
things
and eventually the truth that came about
was the so-called peace of westphalia
which established the modern nation
state
i was just thinking how how happy it
makes me that you thought i might even
know that i
i'm so uh honored
so thank you but uh please please
continue i don't i don't wanna i don't
wanna take us off track
but uh that just it made my day that
just made my day
i don't mean to drop an obscure
reference and there's lots of lots of
areas of history that i don't know about
but this is one that i think about a lot
because
it's highly relevant i think to the
present day in many many different ways
arguably
the 30 years war arose out of the
introduction of the printing press
um because you could go and mimio graph
you know
all of martin luther stuff and spread to
people and that's how you know you did
the software install
boom into people's brains and that's
protestant reformation distribution you
know took off
so this technology gave rise to this
huge fight
that essentially redrew the map and the
concept of the nation state was born out
of that which is
okay you don't have these transnational
entities
that just can have influence everywhere
instead we're going to have these sort
of
geographically defined areas that are
the sovereign government with a monopoly
of violence
and a religion can't just walk in there
and just start
washing people around there's like a
lawful government that was the truth
that people came to you stay in your
lane i see in mine
just out of all the bloodshed and to
stop the bloodshed so
i think we've just began hopefully
there's not bloodshed or
not much of it i think we've just begun
people think
we're ending it but i think we've just
begun the global internet
like cold war where all of these social
networks currency networks compete
for ideological and economic dominance
around the world because they can just
spread virally back and forth like this
and um
everyone will be trying to cancel each
other and whatnot it's going to be this
crazy crazy thing
you know for example one thing i
anticipate will happen sometime in the
2020s
is i think in some country probably the
us
for lots of reasons i think the cloud
will burst
and what i mean by that is some you know
like treasury was just recently hacked
with the solar winds thing
people don't know what they got they
could have gotten every tax return they
could have gotten all kinds of very
sensitive stuff
and it was hacked with with what i'm
sorry oh solar
solar winds is sort of the name of the
hack and you got it
and the scope of it is not fully
understood it's like this total ownage
of all kinds of government systems and
this is not the first time this has
happened it's also happened at
the government of texas and so and so
forth they're not pointing at any
particular
entity the main thing is when there's a
recent hack of
ledger the crypto company their database
was
just blast on the internet and you could
actually uh you know i wasn't a customer
but people could see
their name and their home address
on the internet and they're like a
crypto
fanatic who has a hardware wallet on
there what a nightmare
what a nightmare oh my god and and so it
is like this
thing where you know you don't um you
can't easily change your home i mean
some people can yeah suddenly you have
guys in track suits showing up at your
house
potentially exactly it's like a rancor
list of who holds crypto
really really really sucks may lead to
home invasions other kinds of things
very bad piece of information to have
out there it's an enriched list
so it's hard for you know the thing is
even discussing it i hate bringing more
attention to it other hand
it's also something which has important
consequences and one of the consequences
is
that shows it's not a theoretical risk
to think about what these hacks could be
so far people have talked about hacks
kind of in the abstract
but once a government database is hacked
and all of this surveillance on us
is just blasted out on the internet the
cloud bursts
you know whether it's what what does
that mean like by the cloud all
facebook dms rain down all slacks
rain down something like that raindown
meaning are suddenly searchable
and available in a consumption wikileaks
style
exactly now when that happens the
defense
that people are now it'll cause all
kinds of crazy stuff basically
it's not so much that you'll see fires
and
and electrical outages and so on but
like all kinds of social damage will be
caused
low trust relationships broken all that
type of stuff like that
the tearing of the social fabric go
ahead well i was just gonna say not to
mention
that even if you feel like you have
nothing to hide this is an issue with a
lot of
surveillance act bills and things like
that if
suddenly every lawmaker
every member of congress has dirt on
them
i mean the destabilizing effect yeah is
non-trivial
it's not tricky now there's an argument
that when everybody's naked no one is
some people may make it right right sure
but it doesn't all happen at once that's
the thing right it's not all discovered
simultaneously nor distributed
simultaneously
exactly that's right and if you look at
what happened during the sony hack and
so on this is like a preview of that
and so the answer i think is we're going
to need to build
a pseudonymous economy where over the
medium to long term
you separate out your real name your
earning name and your speaking name and
in fact you have multiple earning names
and multiple speaking names
just like you have multiple usernames at
different sites crypto is a crucial
component of this because it allows you
to earn pseudonymously
and with a recent innovation that you
know i've encoded it up but i've got
like the white paper level
description of it would let you transfer
reputation from one student to another
so one issue right now just to frame the
problem is you may have a bunch of
reputation
followers or karma for example under a
username even a sydney if you boot up
another student it starts at absolutely
zero
which is one of the big things that stop
people from doing it let's say you know
for example
you have a large twitter following and
you boot up a new sydney
that pseudonym starts with nothing and
so it takes you
time to boot up like a new
following that's a whole effort that
deters a lot of people from doing it
they're starting all the way from
scratch
and you know i thought about this
problem and how to because the thing is
that with
cryptocurrency we've actually solved
this where you can set up a username and
another username and you can use zcash
to transfer money from one name to
another
pseudonymously so money can be
transferred reputation though
didn't seem to be until i realized that
actually you might not be able to do it
for followers
which are non-fungible that i say one
person is not like the same as the other
but you could do it on a site like
reddit where you had karma that was
accumulated
and so someone who had 10 000 karma
under one pseudonym
just like you use zcash to transfer
digital currency
zcash is basically like the truly
anonymous version of bitcoin truly
private version of bitcoin
just like you z cash to transfer cash
from one name to another you could use z
karma
to transfer karma from one username to
another and thereby
reboot under a new username okay and
that username would have no
comment history but people would be like
okay that's a 50 000 karma person or
whatever the number is
clear that somebody who our community
esteems
to some extent you know has been
uploaded a lot perhaps we should listen
to what they have to say
because they felt they had to go into a
pseudonym for this and of course you
could do this with
not just a global karma but subreddit
specific karma
you accumulated all this karma in the i
don't know the historian subreddit or
the mathematician subreddit or something
like that you have something
controversial to get off your chest you
can say it this way that's one dimension
of the pseudonymous economy
i think another dimension is basically
that people
just like you don't give out your
password you know i think it's going to
become
less and less and less common for people
to
give out the mapping between
their physical body and their usernames
online
like you may not even tell your wife you
know just like you know people
when you mean physical mapping that just
means you you're not going to
correlate those two things for someone
that's right exactly right so so
essentially
it will be considered a faux pas and
we're already moving towards this right
like there's this uh this youtuber
uh whose name i forget who's like [ __ ]
is that he's like a
faceless guy like faceless horror or
something like that what's his name
i'm talking about i don't know but we'll
we'll put it we'll find it and put it in
the show notes
okay yeah so this guy's name
corpse husband corpse husband
never heard of it okay c-o-r-p-s-e
husband corpse husband so this guy with
this
super deep voice who sounds like this
you know like like like a like
i can't even i can't even mimic it this
guy with a super deep voice has never
shown his face
so corp's husband basically
you know he's quasi anonymous he's
giving away his audio but not his video
and you know i think that stuff like
that i mean what's with i think what's
going to happen
soon sooner than we think probably by
2025 2030 latest
is you'll have filters on your zoom
that are not simply like oh my
background is san francisco or whatever
but audio and video filters so that you
sound and look like a different person
and that will be like the equivalent of
clothes the fbi informant filter
something like that or it's just just
something where people don't need to
know who you are
and yeah here's where i think why i call
this a piece of west folly i think at
the end of this
rainbow is not the right metaphor but
this journey pseudonymd stops both
discrimination
and cancellation so it is it's not ideal
but it is accepted and widely used by
people of
all political persuasions and so it's
sort of like a mutual disarmament
where you can't cancel somebody the only
thing you can do is judge them by what
they're saying
you can't discriminate against somebody
you don't even know what their immutable
characteristics are
and so that's actually i think an
acceptable truce
to many parties not a great one but
it's a total opposite of bring your full
self to work google stuff or whatever
it's actually the total opposite
trade-off which is minimum necessary
assault
and i think this goes hand in hand with
a future world where there's more
tasking more micro work less full-time
jobs and so on some of the stuff
obviously you've touched on many times
all right so there are lots of questions
i could ask including
what are we've talked about what it
stops but not what it
produces or what uh side effects or
perverse incentives could could
come into play with a pseudonymous
economy i think we might get into that
but i just want to ensure that i
don't miss asking a question and this is
really a meta question of sorts and if
it's a shitty question you can tell me
and we'll do something else sure i had
for context
as you mentioned or maybe as i mentioned
i think it was on january 30th
of 2020 this is a week after the
lockdown in the city of wuhan
you posted a tweet what if this
coronavirus is the pandemic that public
health people have been warning about
for years
and you ended up predicting accurately
many things related to kovid
you have certainly
been a participant and
in some respects by participating a
predictor of
many developments in blockchain and
cryptocurrency
and for that reason i had a laundry list
of questions related to different types
of
possible predictions that you might have
but i thought
a broad strokes way of checking all
those boxes
might be and tell me if this makes any
sense or if you're
game to try this is to actually talk
about investing
and just to say if someone handed you a
hundred thousand dollars or a hundred
million dollars today
and you had to invest it
how would you even think about that
because i think by answering that it
might
it might actually begin to
speak to some of your predictions
in the upcoming years sure you think
about that framing
sure so basically i mean like i never
give financial advice
right well i was just going to say right
what is important there's a disclaimer
yeah
what would you do this is not financial
advice we're not registered investment
advisors
caveat amp tour this is for
informational purposes only
no miners or minotaurs allowed et cetera
et cetera please continue
sure so the question is if i was given a
hundred thousand or 100 million dollars
what do i do with that like how do i
maximize returns so the dumbest thing
but that i think is the most obvious
thing to do is put half into bitcoin
half into a theorem
the dumbest meaning the simplest or the
the most ill-advised
no no the simplest like the simplest
thing that i think is
you know guaranteed to produce really
exceptional returns
i think you could probably do i mean in
retrospect from
i don't know 2030 looking back there'd
probably be something you could do that
would be bet not probably there will be
almost certainly something you could do
that would be better than that
but that's going to do extremely well
okay i think it's a global strategy also
is that what you is that what you would
do now understanding you've
you've sold multiple companies you've
had multiple exits you are
post-economic in i assume in that
respect
but you said to maximize returns and i'm
not i'm not sure if
that is how you would think of the
objective at this point
so is it objective to make the maximum
difference to humanity or is it to
maximize returns what
was your it's whatever you would do with
it oh okay well what i would do is
something very different so
i thought you meant invest on behalf of
somebody else okay well you you well in
a sense you answered that so i i'd love
to
to hear your your personal take sure
okay so
i'll tell you what at least i'm i'm
planning on doing which is
pouring money some of some of my own and
maybe you know some from investors if i
decide to raise money into bootstrapping
talent around the world through 1729 so
just return to that because we were
talking about that at the beginning
this is going to be the first newsletter
that pays you and so that's to say
daily at least a thousand dollars in
bitcoin prizes
for doing tasks okay so for example
here's an essay the best 10 responses to
it get 100 bucks in bitcoin
here is a scientific article
the best 140 second video on this gets a
thousand dollars that explains it to the
masses
here is a textbook or a chapter of a
textbook
please generate 10 exercises for this
chapter that are fully open source that
anybody can do
i'll give you a hundred dollars in
bitcoin each so that's cumulative like
an open source
coursera open source wikipedia in a
sense and the goal here in doing
this is several-fold first is i want to
actually
build up those citizen journalists that
we talked about those content creators
second i want to invest in
like a cumulative form of education open
source education you know where
these folks are doing tutorials so for
example those 10 questions i just
mentioned that could be on science
but they could be on video editing or
other kinds of things and it's all just
open source
so that people get paid for creating the
educational tasks that others can do
how are those two things related by the
way i know it seems a little vague but
let me let me explain so you have these
tasks that people are completing
and you have educational content that
people are creating the reason they're
related
is there's global tasks that anybody can
do
but you might be able to get paid more
if you know figma
or if you know python or if you know
chemistry
and so the educational tasks that i also
pay people to do are like a curriculum
that if you solve these tasks you can
level up and get higher value
remunerative tasks the basic idea is go
ahead
may i pause you for a second so if you
have a task like create 10 exercises
based on this textbook or this material
can multiple people perform that or
complete that task if so
do you pay all of them how do you decide
who to pay that's a great question so
the review process actually we allocate
as much of a budget or a good chunk of
the budget just to review
because review is its own thing and
there's various ways of doing review
and we're going to experiment with a
crowdsourced aspect like a reddit style
leaderboard of up and down voting
and then a manual you know review on top
of that and then there's like 50
different things that you can do
to kind of make this more sophisticated
in a sense this is like
earn.com 3.0 you know there's earn.com
there's coinbase earn
which earn.com is actually doing
extremely well before we sold to
coinbase was essentially
pay people to reply to emails and
complete tasks
and then coinbase earn was asset issuers
like uh you know creators of new
cryptocurrencies and digital assets
would pay users to do tutorials on their
asset to learn about how it worked you
know like
file coin or orchard how to use
decentralized storage or decentralized
vpn
and this is like a third iteration which
also combines a bunch of ideas that i've
had
for online education so just to
summarize it again
a a newsletter that pays you with at
least a thousand dollars a day
in bitcoin prizes for completing tasks
and tutorials
and then b what this does is hopefully
it bootstraps talent all over the world
anywhere there's a phone there's a job
right we can give this sky hook to
people
and you can just start with nothing
absolutely nothing other than this phone
which people have made really cheap
and you can do the tutorials you learn
some skills you level up you get more
tasks
you start leveling up more you get
digital currency so anywhere there's a
phone there's a job and there's an
education
and this is what i plan to do with you
know what i've been fortunate enough to
to make and that's my contribution to
humanity i think
or hope it to be and uh and hopefully
this helps find also like the next
ramanujans out there
who is this kid in brazil or the middle
east you know somebody in some war-torn
area like syria it's all bombed out
but hopefully that kid has a smartphone
and we can like kind of airlift them out
right give them a shot
if they're willing to put in the work
and you know be all free so let me pause
there that's that's at least what i'm
thinking about doing
and i know it's an idiosyncratic use of
capital but i'm not the type to spend on
ferraris or whatever
yeah i would expect no less so let's
just say
that there is a bright kid
in syria who i'm struggling so much
because i'm accustomed to saying
ramanujan but i'm getting that incorrect
like so ramanajin
and he's performing or she
is performing various tasks at a high
level
what do you then do with that talent so
presumably they develop
some type of reputational score
or they accrue some type of reputation
how do you airlift that kid out or
encourage them
to airlift themselves out is it the
capital is it that they now have the
resources to
in greater optionality to perhaps
improve their situation
or is there another approach because
they could be brilliant and continue to
complete these microtasks right so three
thoughts there right so first is
of course you know syria is an unusual
case because it's actually a war zone
but
we could use another example if it's
easier so so let's say
you know it's nigeria or it's india or
it's a place where maybe the kid doesn't
actually want to leave if they don't
want to leave
now they have their cake and eat it too
they can have
home-cooked food they can have their
local culture and local language
but they can also get into the internet
fastly
and they can contribute pseudonymously
ideally you know to a community that
will neither discriminate against them
nor cancel them
because the accent doesn't matter their
age doesn't matter skin color doesn't
matter gender doesn't matter none of
those things matter can't matter that's
at least my ideal
the true global meritocracy and that's
international of course
and so the concept here is yes they
would start earning and the thing is a
thousand bucks
even once in a year is actually a lot of
money for people in a lot of places
so that's like quite a lot of people
that we can airlift out that way when i
say airlift
as i said i don't necessarily mean
remove them from that location
unless they want to leave they might be
able to stay there i mean more like
airlift them from whatever situation
they're in
at least give them the opportunity and
uh what does that mean in practice well
one of the most important things it does
i think is this is the
if again if this works ambitious and
it's crazy and so but let me try and
explain it anyway
this is actually the digital native
solution to education
here's what i mean by that so you can
think of a
piece of paper and then you can think of
a scanner and you can think of a text
file right so you go from
physical to this hybrid physical to
digital scanner and then digital native
another example would be
you got a face-to-face meeting you've
got zoom
and then you've got virtual reality zoom
is also like a scanner
it's taking the offline and putting it
online but then vr is like digital
native
third example physical cache
then something like paypal or fintech
right which is just
basically the scanner taking then
putting it online
and then you have crypto which swaps out
the back end
is just now natively digital it doesn't
have a physical form and
with education you have at least higher
education
offline you've got the physical college
then you've got the scanner
which is like audacity and coursera and
so on which are fine companies good
companies billion dollar companies you
know
but they're basically taking the college
experience and putting it online and
then there's this really interesting
terra incognita
of what does digital native education
look like so
let me kind of motivate how that works
and then you can see how maybe that
links in with the tasking piece um and i
say this is someone who's taught a lot
of courses whatever and
you know so this at least it may be a
mistake but it comes from
my experience of mistakes forever so
let's say you take a stanford degree in
computer science
there are on the order of 25 courses you
need to complete the degree
give or take and that's in addition to
so-called graduate education
requirements
and each one is roughly each course
roughly 10 weeks and say
on the order of 10 problems per week
sometimes more sometimes less
so that means about 2500 problems 25
times 10 times 10.
you need to solve 2500 problems before
you get
your one degree so it's like you have
zero degrees
at problem 2300 and then you have one
degree after problem 2500. i carry
catcher up but not by much
and after you have your one degree you
go and now you can actually
get paid and you can work and so on and
so forth that's a historical thing get
your degree and then work
now of course this is only an
idealization people will do paid
internships and so on during college
so after you know 500 problems they have
enough qualification to go and get some
you know job or internship that's true
but to first order this is how this the
system
is still meant to work right get your
diploma before you get a job
now one of the things people used to say
a sort of a caricature or
attack or whatever of uh audacity
udacity of these nano degrees they say
oh you're getting a nano degree well you
better expect an anti-salary
you know oh hahaha right it's crap
whatever so the thing about that
is what if you take that seriously what
if you say
all right rather than this step function
this discontinuous thing we have to
solve 2500 problems
before you get a job that's paying 100k
what if you solve
five problems and i give you a job that
pays you ten bucks
a microtask and we see how you do on
that that
radically reduces the risk for both
sides your risk in terms of
you know spending all this time learning
something and the employer's risk
and uh and frankly you know the
difference between a person who solved
five problems or one problem in
javascript versus zero
is actually a big difference it's
surprising you know that's actually a
big difference so the idea here
is that if you could show proof of skill
somehow right if i could demonstrate
that i have some skill in javascript or
i have some
skill in chemistry or or skill in
illustrator or whatever
then i could qualify for more skilled
micro tasks right as opposed to the
mechanical turk style lowest common
denominator which is fine
but that's just like labeling something
as a cat or a dog all you need is a
pulse
it's the uh the recaptcha style thing
that you see you know label the cars
that type of stuff is fine but that's
like just all you need is a pulse you
don't need any skill
the question then becomes how do you
actually do proof of skill and i think
the answer is something and i've got a
post coming on this which i call the
crypto credential
and the idea is every time you solve one
of these problems
we don't give you karma like on hacker
news
we give you a little batch that says you
solved that problem
and that's held in your digital wallet
just like your cryptocurrency think of
it as an nft if you know what nfts are
so it is an enft basically right
um except it's non-transferable and just
uh just a side note for people who are
interested in learning more about nfts
or non-fungible tokens from remembering
correctly
katie han and i discuss this at length
in that podcast episode which you can
which you can find
elsewhere so just google her name
h-a-u-n and my name and it'll pop right
up so
please continue awesome okay yes no
katie's awesome
so the idea is this would be uh this is
not something you can resell
so it's not enough to sound like a piece
of art in that sense it's a it's a third
application or
ant application of crypto it's not
cryptocurrency it's not
art it is a crypto credential it's
awarded to you and
uh you know the the first version of
those are just you solve problems on a
website and you earn these crypto
credentials
just like you earn badges at stack
overflow just like you earn badges in a
video game you earn these crypto
credentials
the difference being they're on chain
and because they're on chain
you can log into any site with them and
now you can qualify for instant jobs
microtasks now here's what's cool about
this there's a lot of details in how we
implement this which i can get into
but what's cool about this is it levels
it all out you know yes absolutely
there's smart people at
harvard or mit or stanford but there's
smart people in the middle of brazil
and you know in hungary and india and
nigeria and the philippines
and i know there's more people there
because i could see them in my class
and i could see that many of them were
the equal or the better
of you know some of the more pampered
kids at these expensive schools
especially nowadays
where there's less stress on just
getting the right answer and more on
canceling people or whatever right like
undergrad is much more screwed than what
especially in the us than it was you
know even 20 years ago 10 years ago
plus because the pandemic lots of
colleges are shut down and they're
having
economic problems there's a huge desire
to do something
better and the concept is you know if we
do this right it's like
wikipedia for education because every
course is open source
the problems are out there it's like an
open source curriculum
we're going to build it on the exorcism
framework at least that's my thinking
right now i might change my mind but
exercism.io this is an awesome site by
the way it's got a funny name too like
exorcism but with an e
and exorcism basically has something
where you can learn python by doing like
50 python problems
or you can learn javascript by doing
like 70 javascript problems
and it's recorded on the site it's like
you see this counter go up
and just think about how much better
that is than typical social media where
all you're doing is
fighting for clicks or whatever you know
fighting for hearts on twitter
or likes on facebook whatever it is and
that's something where you're just
incrementing numbers on somebody else's
server i'm not saying it has zero value
there is some value to it but it's not
value that you can easily
quantify or extract from the system you
know you build up your followers there
you can't import them or export them
it's not really building up yourself the
idea behind 7029.com
would be you would constantly be
pursuing
your improving your knowledge
and your bank account you can also be
learning and earning
you'd be learning and getting these
crypto credentials and then that would
allow you to earn cryptocurrency
now the third thing actually and this is
something i've been also thinking about
flirting with idea of and maybe we'll do
this is
you may think this is crazy but you're
also the four hour body guy so
i'm already crazy i think i've crossed
across that rubicon a long time ago all
right
so so the third thing i was also
thinking about is actually putting up um
a third kind of daily post
which is burning that's to say just
post something of you working out and we
give the
100 best each day like ten dollars in
btc and
that's it's a varied health task it's
not just working out maybe it's
show your fitness tracker or what
vitamins are using
or something like that with the goal
being that
people who are at safety training and
are focused on
truth health wealth learning true things
and leveling themselves up that way like
gaining knowledge
health like improving their body their
physique but also
you know like staving off aging you know
thinking about transhumanism measuring
themselves
and then wealth as important but third
truth health and wealth in that order
because
you know determine what's true make sure
to maximize your health
and then accumulate wealth but don't do
it at the expense of what is true or
what is good for your health go ahead
you're smiling
i love that i love it because uh i mean
not to bring this to the four-hour body
seems like uh a downgrade but
the the five i mean like i'm very proud
of that book and happened right but
the and a lot of what was in there that
seemed highly speculative at the time
has
has only uh gained more traction and
support and literature and so on so i'm
very pleased with that
a large component of that and especially
the four-hour chef which can very
confusingly is about accelerated
learning and behavioral change
the disproportionate impact of small
incentives
and stakes is i just think so under
discussed and one of the stories that i
tell
in uh the four-hour body i believe was
of a google engineer who
hoped to get in shape and he created a
pact
with a fellow engineer which was we're
going to work out together
whatever it was three days a week and if
either of us misses a workout we're
gonna pay the other person
a dollar now these are google engineers
they make
more than a few dollars a year and it
was incredibly effective
and the fact that it's a micro incentive
leading to a micro behavior should not
be minimized because ultimately
our life is largely comprised of
longitudinal
accrual of these micro behaviors it's a
big [ __ ] deal
so i love that idea i love that idea let
me backstep if i could sure
i knew this was going to happen so no
surprise here but i realized that i did
not deliver on the promise of one of my
questions and that question was related
to so we're going to focus on the
earning component here for a moment just
because i
i want to ensure that i provide what i
promised to the listeners
i asked the what would you personally
do in this case to maximize return with
100k or 100 million
and then we didn't dig into the
predictions or assumptions underlying
your answer
hi so the answer was half in btc bitcoin
half in ethereum
and i'd love to hear you comment on
number one the assumptions of what's
going to happen
or not happen that makes that a a
rational
investment and number two and maybe you
can answer this first
if you could paint a picture
of what you consider the risk profile to
be in doing something like that
and again this isn't investment advice
is part of the calculus
an assumption that this is a 10 or 100 x
or it's a zero
or something else if you could just
speak to that sure
sure so i mean look it's crypto so
you know crypto is crazy and it's uh
it's very difficult to predict exactly
what's going to happen
um with anything but you know but the
the two things i said that i
do with the money are you know there's
return on investment there's like return
to society
and what's interesting is actually when
you talk about the you know so return on
investment is fifty percent btc five
percent eth return to society is
the sort of open source education
tasking
truth health well thing and you know by
the way truth health and wealth i think
of as
the next liberte egalite fraternity it's
the slogan of the next state which i'll
come to
okay or one one of the next states but
but coming back up the stack so
both of those things actually have
common premises underneath them
which is that i am simultaneously very
bearish
on the u.s specifically in the west
generally but very bullish
on the internet technology crypto
asia and you know future progress and
those are not normally
often somebody is very positive on one
and positive in the other or vice versa
now they're they're actually separated
out they're separated out things because
nor for a long time people associate
technological progress of the usa
and now technological progress is
something that doesn't benefit
the us establishment they don't win a
game the east coast establishment does
not win a game of free speech and free
markets
and so that's why they're clamping down
on free speech and free markets because
if everybody has a voice especially
around the world
go ahead why do they not could you just
say a few more lines
on why that's the case sure so why they
don't win that game
why those things are bad for the east
coast establishment well so
you know a small example of not winning
a game of free markets
whether it's the bailouts whether it is
all the regulations that protect them
or the whole gamestop thing you know
where it definitely looked like some
strings were pulled somewhere
i'm not saying the robin hood thing you
know because i think vlad gave a pretty
good
you know explanation of that you know
for people who follow that whole
scenario
but certainly discord going and just
shutting down gamestop discussion out of
nowhere based on
i think a pretext seemed like someone
pulled some string somewhere to make
that happen and that's something where
truly free markets maybe wall street
doesn't win right there's
there's a rigging that's going on i see
so by east coast establishment just to
be clear you mean specifically in the
financial sector do you also mean
dc media dc harvard like basically the
legacy
kind of entities in the us right like
the pre-internet establishment
then like free speech that's even more
obvious every single day you have some
new editorial saying something like free
speech is killing us or critical
thinking is bad or
or whatever and uh you know oh i can't
believe people are having unfettered
conversations
right that was like the latest meme and
for many people this is like this
weird thing where houses that the us
that they grew up in has suddenly just
done a 180 on this
and the answer is that those folks have
legacy distribution but they have a
terrible product they can't win the
argument
and because they can't win the argument
they're trying to use their distribution
to shut off other people's distribution
because they know they'd lose the
argument if distribution is open at all
so against free speech against free
markets
and crypto is actually truly free speech
and free markets so that's actually the
true inheritor of the western tradition
it's sort of like the internet is to the
usa what the americas were to the uk
it's like this new world that will
eventually give birth to the successor
and crypto is like a huge huge part of
all that because it
captures you know the part of the west
it's actually globally admirable you
know
unambiguous rule of law except in smart
contracts protection from search and
seizure
through encryption you know all that
type of stuff coming back up you ask the
why why did you not win this game right
because first is
empirical observation what's the
underlying thing well
uh they basically become these inbred
folks
they are not selecting on talent anymore
they are selecting on connections
reflecting on whether you are the son of
the son of the son or the daughter of
the
daughter of the daughter it is not
something where they are actually taking
the best folks they are taking the folks
who can just repeat a party line
i think that's one huge component of it
just for sake of clarity do you mean
within corporate entities therefore
contrasting sort of discuss media for
example take a look at how many of those
folks
went to private school how many of these
folks have a trust fund
how many of those folks inherited a
fortune just for me
how does that tie to the btc eth
ah how does that talk how's that those
folks
they lack the skills to win in a fair
competition
so there there's various rigging that
was done most obviously with the
bailouts of 2008 there's so many other
you know items of this that's just a
very high profile one and in response to
that
technologists developed bitcoin and
ethereum
and these free systems i mean like if
you look at the genesis block it says
it references the bailouts in the
genesis block of bitcoin where
it's essentially the counter to this
sort of
nepotistic east coast establishment and
uh you know to me that's like super
obvious
but you're right that it's actually
useful to kind of lay out the full logic
of it because
one of the consequences here or one of
the medium term
things is you can only use
force to kind of clamp down on global
free speech and free markets for so long
it's like a jack in the box that will
just pop
out somehow one way i think about that
is after the financial crisis
basically you know the way that they
decided to like stop the next crisis is
they made it almost impossible to get a
banking charter so
you punish the banks by eliminating all
their competition
now somehow fintech and crypto found a
way
different threads coming to the same
thing where basically like working above
doing partnerships working below
like despite the front door being closed
technology came in through the windows
and the chimney or what happened
and it's actually sort of reforming the
system against their will like
dodd-frank
did not reform the banks it just sort of
enshrined them it was
it was a you know a coronation in the
name of a regulation right
yeah it did reduce some of their profit
levels in some ways but it made them
look more invulnerable go ahead you're
gonna say
no i'm just i'm smiling i'm enjoying so
for those who
who who can't see us because we're
probably not gonna be publishing video
we're
we're we are currently on video so we
can watch each other's facial
expressions
please continue sure yeah i like i like
i like the
uh the coronation disguised as
regulation right
right exactly right you know so so it is
it is literally picking winners because
you're writing the regulation that
assumes a certain structure
and capital requirements i mean like the
concept of a smart contract was not
contemplated in dodd-frank
you know like like a contract that could
be executed independently of a judge or
a person
okay what's my point point is as faith
in the pre i mean i don't think many
institutions that predated the internet
will survive the internet
it is this universal acid and the reason
is
because it connects people peer-to-peer
and so what that does
is it one of my laws of
internet physics is the internet
increases variance
okay why so first let me give the
observation right the observation is
uh you go from 30 minute sitcoms to 30
episode netflix binges
or 30 second youtube clips you go from
you know a stable nine to five job to a
20 something billionaire or a 40 year
old failed son who's
made nothing of themselves you go from a
taxi ride
you know it's standard taxi ride to uber
which actually has
very long trips and also very short ones
like the whole thing is spread out
relative to the ride
time of the normal taxi and the reason
for this
like this is a very common thing in
every area like in every i've seen
hundreds probably thousands of companies
at this point i've seen all these graphs
right so you'll
have to believe me that this is a
synthesis of a lot of different graphs
that i've seen
when the internet disrupter comes in
variance increases there's more downside
and more upside
more amazing outcomes and more really
bad outcomes in all kinds of ways
why does that happen because it connects
people peer-to-peer entities
peer-to-peer
it removes the middle man it removes the
mediator
it removes the moderator it removes the
mediocrity
now each of those words has a different
connotation getting to the middle man
everyone shares yay
getting rid of the moderator people are
like oh i'm not so sure give me the
mediocrity again everybody cheers
so those are all kind of similar words
but they mean
somewhat different implications but
they're all true at the same time
so uh what happens is you have these
communities that then arise where nodes
that can never connect to each other
boom they form some
bizarre subreddit or some amazing thing
like eth research
you know which is put you know or y
combinator so you it's like uh
and if you've ever centrifuged anything
have your centrifuge anything
this is i can finally say yes to
something yes okay all right great so
you centrifuge and you get these
different layers out right this
you know mostly samples of some tissue
or fluid from my own body
there you go right so so if you
centrifuge something you see all the
layers just
you can often see them just in the test
tube itself and you're like whoa that
was like a slurry before but now it's
like
very defined there's a supernatant in
those layers and um
in the same way that's what the internet
is doing it's just like
basically taking all of these previously
mediating
mediocre moderating middleman
institutions and just
nuking them all and they're like trying
to fight back but
they won't make it the centrifugal force
is too much i think
the one exception might be the chinese
communist party
that might be the exception that proves
the rule just because they were like
super early on a lot of this they built
a firewall
they may be the exception that proves
rule and the future may be
a centralized east versus decentralized
west where
what what i think happens in the west
did you see this greater idaho thing for
example
have i seen which greater idaho so a
bunch of counties in oregon
want to break away from oregon and merge
with idaho catalonia
wants to break away from spain all of
these there's all these breakaway
movement
type things or whatever happening it's
like a it's like a rumbling you know
that's happening
quebec you know there are quite a few
examples of i mean i have a
texas t-shirt that says most likely to
secede
with a picture of the state not that
that is
well actually you could look into the
some of the formation
documents so to speak of text it's kind
of fun but yes i'm not familiar with
greater idaho but i'm familiar with the
the breakaway the breakaways the
breakaway movement and the thing about
that
is i think some of that is bad some of
that is good
but the centrifugal force like it's it's
the whole thing is juddering
right the system is juddering um because
folks are unhappy with it
and i think one of the reasons for that
is you know the
the going back to westfalia one of the
westfalian assumptions
is that people who are geographically
proximal are ideologically proximal
that say you live next door to this guy
therefore you share his language you
share his culture you share the norms
for the most part
you know them you say hi to them all the
type of stuff in the modern era
people live in these apartment buildings
where they couldn't recognize somebody
who lives 10 feet away from them but
they're sharing the most intimate
moments
with people 3000 miles away via snapchat
or twitter or whatever
so this variance just
again to to try to tie some of these
threads together
the variants increased by the internet
and what you're describing
these are to the benefit of
in this case bitcoin and ethereum yes
yes and and now the reason is there are
examples of the extreme upside
they're examples of like several things
at the same time right
first uh those middle men are going away
you know the
whether it's the the old nation states
um i mean
they'll fight don't get me wrong you
know it's not going to be a you know
trivial thing some of them will reform
i'll come to that point i don't think
every state just goes away i'm not like
a total tech utopianist in that sense
but first there's a loss of faith in the
past
and that makes people open to turning a
constant into a variable
a dollar sign this fixed dollar that
everybody knew into well i could have
fiat or crypto
something that was a constant is now a
variable fiat or crypto before it was
just fiat it wasn't even thought of as
fiat was even
was fiat even a word ten years ago i
mean like it people people might
have never heard it you never heard it
right but i thought it was
it was car i think it was a car when i
was a kid and now it's
crypto exactly that's right that's right
so so um
or rather it's opposite of crypto okay i
see i'm sorry you're right you're right
it was it was a car
jesus well i'm tie myself up in knots
here yeah it was a sh
a a shitty car and now it's a shitty
debased
currency yeah exactly that's right right
so so essentially
um many things we have taken to be
constants have been turned into
variables
because they were constants due to that
mediating influence
and once people could connect here on
the internet you could see there are
actually more permutations and more
levels and those people start to gain
more of a voice
and that's true in so many different
areas i just point out you know this one
you know for example just the digital
versus physical versions of everything
you have to specify whether it's a snail
mail or an email
20 years ago now it's almost all email
so or the meeting is an in-person
meeting or an online meeting
the reason that btc and eth are
important is
first they represent the sort of
unbundling from the old system where
it's no longer able to corral all the
nodes the nodes don't all trust it
it isn't performing the functions that
they all wanted and the top ones can now
escape to build something better which
they did on the internet
and that i think becomes the new center
that people align around
like the digital native kind of thing
because i don't believe that you just
have all these particles flying around
forever i think we're in the age of
unbundling and then eventually
rebundling i mean you know like there's
that thing by jim barksdale right the
only way he knew
how to make money on the internet was on
bundling and bundling it was a very
funny kind of thing it's also true
you know you think about you unbundle
all the songs from
all the uh albums then you rebundle them
in spotify playlists
you unbundle every single article and
website and url in the world and you
rebundle them into
a twitter feed you unbundle
all of these different well actually
there's there's a lot of things i could
talk about with unbundling here
but you unbundle all these different
products and uh you have them on amazon
and you rebound them into like shopping
lists or whatever there so you can click
and just buy like 50 things at once that
are
they're sort of by it's as if you have
your own store shelf
this is your prepper shopping list and
there's there's a thousand things like
this if you think about the unbundling
and rebundling
but i think the next step is because
states of mind and nation states no
longer map to each other
because people are friends with millions
of people around the world who share
their values but they're not physically
concentrated
the physical areas have less
volition by their subjects so they have
to
enact more coercion and more coercion in
turn leads to less volition and leads to
less legitimacy
and that's a negative feedback loop
where at the same time people are
building bonds with other folks of like
mind that are geographically despairing
and that is something that's exerting
like a strain on the whole system
which i think eventually results in mass
migrations
and people assembling into communities
of like mind
to sort of rebuild civil society with
folks who they agree with ideologically
and that's already kind of happening
with hacker houses and so i wrote an
article on this by the way eight years
ago
in 2013 i think it's really starting to
happen well i think it's
it's certainly happening in a uh on a
small scale i mean i'm very
i'm aware of a number of concrete
examples in places like utah upstate new
york
and so on where this has been i think
dramatically accelerated by covet yep
and
a mass exodus at least for the time
being i don't think this is permanent
but out of
city centers to question not to belabor
this point but i think it's a useful
tool to use in the conversation in the
case of btc and eth
how would you think about downside risk
and what would need to happen or what
might happen
or not happen that would make them bad
investments
great question so i think that for btc
because it's like a 10 year old protocol
the attack on btc that i think would be
the most likely
is that the chinese put up the great
firewall against it so it's a network
level attack
as opposed to a mining attack because
the thing is that bitcoin assumes
that every node can reach every other
node so or every mining node can reach
every other mining node
so it assumes a global internet if you
put up the firewall
you can work out the kind of predator
prey on this but you know they block
port a333 and the bitcoin devs do port
randomization and then they do
you know deep packet inspection and
these guys do tunneling to try to put it
over ssh or https there's a back and
forth that can happen there
i think at the end of the day the
firewall is pretty sophisticated and it
will
that plus like domestic penalties may
make it challenging for people to
maintain a blockchain indefinitely in
china
or what would happen is they mine the
china chain
and the rest of the world chain is also
being mined and there's like a peekaboo
problem
where they sync up every once in a while
and because
the china chain would have more mining
the rest of the world chain would have
less mining
all the blocks mined the rest of the
world would get thrown away with a chain
reorganization and the china chain would
basically periodically throw away every
transaction that was happening the rest
world that would be
like the worst case scenario where
remember two things would have to happen
there
first they'd have to put up the firewall
and second they would have to allow
chinese mining to continue
at some point as you're describing this
i'd love to hear you
assign a probability if you had to like
zero to a hundred percent
over a time frame right like in the next
five or ten years i'd say
thirty percent chance of a firewall
attack it's not a hundred percent
the reason is because it's just
something i mean bitcoin
is like a guy who's like extremely
strong and muscular
on many dimensions but can be hit from a
direction over here which is just
it's just an assumption the protocol is
that every node can reach every other
node
and depending on the location of where
mining is happening
and so now to be clear i don't think
this is a fatal blow i think what would
happen
is in the event that china allowed
mining to continue but put up the
firewall which is like the most
machiavellian thing they could do
they're pretty smart
right and the 30 that you assigned was
only for the first part of that
correct not the allowing mining to
continue well if they do both
so so meaning i would rather i think
it's very likely they're going to do a
firewall
attack at some point if they do that and
shut down mining no problem
and the reason is because there's enough
rest of the world or whatever you know
mining to continue it just means that
chinese can only transact in the rest of
the world they have to like
either go overseas or pick up the phone
and speak the words to somebody to
execute a transaction
china will never be able to actually
eliminate bitcoin because of the way
it's constructed
but they could try to seriously if they
really went after it as super
aggressively
they're the only state in the world that
i think has
the combination of total disregard for
individual privacy or human rights
totally organized top-down surveillance
regime
which gets a workout every single day
with a firewall you know
like that combination the us government
can't mail checks to people on time
so a lot of people think the us
government could do some technical the
u.s government isn't capable of a
technical attack the u.s government
can't set up a website
it is not the entity that we know from
the movies
which maybe never existed but you know
the us government from 1933 to 1968
could do like hoover dam and
you know like uh manhattan project and
apollo
that was like a generation that is long
since gone
you can't think of the last impressive
thing that happened go ahead
well i no no i'm i'm just smiling i just
i'm just enjoying this conversation
tremendously uh it's
it's uh it's not because i have
something to say although now that
you've given me the mic
i'll ask a question that perhaps is just
on the mind of people listening
and that is that 30 percent that you
gave does that mean
that biology is saying there's a 30
percent chance of bitcoin being a bad
investment
no but i'm saying something different
which is in the event of such an attack
like a firewall attack
what would happen probably is a few
things
first depending on how it manifests
people might actually
move over to a quasi-trusted chain for a
time
that's to say you'd put some form of
signature or hash
into minors when they put it out there
to prove that they were a non-china
minor
and you'd actually temporarily move away
from the satoshi algorithm of heaviest
proof-of-work chain
to heaviest trusted proof-of-work trend
you actually have to introduce some
trust potentially to get around it
that's one option
the other option is that's like a fork
of the chains and this event that they
do the firewall but they also allow
mining to continue which is like the
most machiavellian thing it's possible
however if there's some other issue with
the bitcoin protocol the thing that i'm
pretty sure
will never disappear is the bitcoin
ledger
that is replicated in so many places
it's so valuable that in the event of
some issue with the bitcoin protocol the
ledger could be imported into
100 other chains and would be it's
already done with all these forex or
whatever right
but you know for example zcash could
just double their supply
from 21 million to 42 million and just
give refuge to all bitcoiners
to just you know kind of snapshots at a
particular time stamp everybody who has
private keys before then
you've got a spot on the zcash ledger
the same thing could happen on ethereum
the same thing could happen and all
these other chains right
so it's as if your stock would get split
into 100 different or a thousand
different instances your private keys
would still
find your future and that you know now
the sum total of all those values
that might be a pricing there's no
question that there might be a price hit
there maybe it's even more who the heck
knows it's just like crypto so
unpredictable i can't even
i can't even say what would happen
because some of the forks have done
extremely well way better than i would
have expected but that would be a tower
of babel moment
where you'd still want to hold on to
your private keys but it would be all
these other chains that would back you
up
so it would be messy but i i don't think
the idea of cryptocurrency can be
defeated at this point
i think any individual chain it remains
to be seen
how robust they are i don't think that
cryptocurrency as a concept goes away
it's similar by the way to file sharing
where napster got sued and kazaa got
sued
the bittorrent and magnet links and the
pirate bay are still around and actually
quite good bitter on streaming is quite
good
what was that uh popcorn time popcorn
time is actually quite a good app
you know that's like basically streaming
with the quality of like in itunes or
whatever picture streaming
so that doesn't mean i'm not saying it
would be a bad investment i think that's
that's the most likely attack i can see
from the chinese side
that's specific to btc for btc yeah yeah
so on the us side so not all
like other algorithms other consensus
algorithms have a greater degree of
partition tolerance built in for example
you know the fundamental thing you'd
have to work out is like tolerance for
extended partitions where a big chunk of
the network can't see another big chunk
of network
and so then you'd have to detect that
you'd have to
maintain a log of which nodes you were
able to reach there's ways of doing this
it's non-trivial it's especially not
trivial in production but it's possible
a lot of smart computer scientists work
so you'd have to have partition tolerant
chains which could exist number one
number two with respect to what the u.s
would do the us will probably do a
regulatory attack
because that's the one part of the state
that's still functional
they can pass regulations and yell at
people and job with them and so on
now what happened in new york with a bit
license i think is a harbinger of what
is to come
new york sort of overestimated their
clout
they're like we're in new york so of
course we're going to regulate all
crypto stuff where you're going to do
you're going to go somewhere else it's
new york it's the best
and that's not what happened instead
what happened was every crypto company
was like actually the world is very big
now
new york is the last place that we're
going to operate like literally last
we'll operate in 49 other states and do
new york last and that just meant that
actually new yorkers got financial
innovation last
rather than first so that one regulation
the bit license
was something where these folks who were
at some point the big apple
quote unquote was number one and they
just overplayed their hand
in an arrogant way because they didn't
understand the guys who got them there
weren't arrogant like that
they were always hungry you know coming
up like there are folks who understood
okay new york has to do this has to do
that
these folks had been born with it they'd
inherited the system they just thought
they always had that leverage
and i think that's a microcosm of what
the u.s might do where it becomes like
super unfriendly for crypto or
it's possible but i think it's also
possible the resistance comes from the
us it's
this is something we have very low
probability on i think it can go many
different ways
the future is uncertain so the
regulatory federal level
regulatory attack in the us you view as
a low probability event
or just a low or just a low consequence
event because
those companies domiciled in the u.s who
are focused on crypto just re-domicile
it's not that easy to just do that for
lots of reasons it is not easy it's not
that easy to just do that right exactly
like so i think
u.s incorporation in the sense of like
being incorporated in the us
is going to be considered like a major
vulnerability in the future i think
after you know like the 2020s and people
ideally will want to incorporate on
chain and
then have jurisdictions that respect
that because that's global rule of law
you know you can put your shareholder
vote in there you can put your board of
directors vote in there
everything can be done on chain in a
better way and then
just like you can print out a document
locally or exchange bitcoin locally
or you know have email work everywhere
you'd basically have local government
system or twitter works everywhere you
know what i mean
local governments would actually adapt
to the unchained realities rather than
vice versa
that's starting to happen so now to the
federal point go ahead
yeah i was just going to say that it
sounds like a a company or
organizational response to federal
regulatory attack i'm wondering what if
anything
individual sort of retail investors who
hold bitcoin could or would do
sure so i'd say i'd say go to miami go
to wyoming
go to places like that maybe colorado
which will be sanctuary cities and
states for crypto
why is that is it just because you have
the first two at least or
no state income tax i don't know because
wyoming and miami have
us it's it's it's not it's not i mean
there's places are low taxes that's not
actually the thing
the mayor of miami it's not related to
that the mayor miami francis suarez is
awesome guy you should follow his
twitter basically may single-handedly
change governance
in the us because he just got out there
and he innovated in a way
he's got the personality of a startup
ceo all right have you followed this at
all the whole miami thing
i haven't and i should so what was the
name one more time please his name is
francis suarez he's the mayor of miami
and last fall somebody after
you know one of my friends actually
after just observing the latest
catastrophe in san francisco i was like
why don't we just all move silicon
valley to miami and francis juarez
retweeted him with
how can i help which is kind of like the
vc you know kind of
cash phrase or whatever right by the way
i'm not cynical about that phrase at all
it is you know there's people who try to
make it into
like something to be mocked or attacked
and making everybody you know
cynical it's actually a good phrase even
if it's even if it's
not lived up to 100 it's way better that
that's said than not said
anyway so you put out how can i help and
then the contrast with california
basically a legislator there told elon
musk fu literally on twitter
and uh elon replied message received
versus how can i help
enormous gap between the two so miami
suddenly
basically began go go ahead you're
laughing
no i'm just i'm shaking my head cause
i'm just like who
how is that a good move i'm just it's
just like it boggles the mind to me how
that
type of response is productive they are
getting local
positive feedback for that they're
people who are cheering them on twitter
after you alone
ha ha ha you know et cetera et cetera
right like stupid peanut gallery type
stuff
yeah and then then elon moves to austin
and there you go
exactly he said master receive got that
out and um this is the thing so suarez
essentially
has recruited all of these tech and
finance people to miami
by literally just being friendly on
twitter and doing coffees with them
welcoming them to the city billions of
dollars in capital
all these companies have now moved to
miami because it's smart yeah that's
smart that's right
and uh you know so essentially you have
uh he spent
i mean like the roi of every tweet has
to be
like a million dollars right if you did
a thousand tweets to recruit
like one billion dollar company to the
city right you can score it however you
want maybe it's not a billion dollars
for the city but
the market cap is going to get
distributed somehow um it's going to be
spent some fraction of that
is roi is phenomenal and the thing about
it is you don't actually need 10 percent
of the world
world's governors or mayors to be like
francis juarez you just need 10
because those folks will be these
technologically progressive
leaders that will recruit tech
and finance to their cities and uh you
know dubai is doing this
sony is doing this switzerland is doing
it chile for a while had a startup chile
program
all of these places now see their
opportunity if they're smart
and many of the legacy mayors don't
understand what's just happened
basically covet has put us into the
remote world
and now you're more like ceo of the city
than a typical mayor
that's so true totally true so the city
you're always selling you are selling
your city
and crucially there's a new path to
power you don't need to go
mayor to governor to president right you
don't need to get on national tv you
don't need to politic an
angle for a spot at the national
convention or
you know go to national media instead by
just
doing sales every day
by doing by essentially getting on
whether it's twitter or
you know some social media platform and
just getting out there
and talking to folks recruiting folks
and pitching your city and improving the
product of your city
he passed he got a build through which
was like oh miami is now like a pro
bitcoin
city and he's like actually it's the
first city to buy bitcoin how often like
the thing about it is oh he also put the
bitcoin white paper on miami.gov here's
the thing
there are a bunch of governments that
are that's right estonia colombia miami
etcetera all in a little boomlit a few
weeks ago
put the bitcoin white paper on their
site that thing is on the one hand of
course that's just a symbol
on their hand it's actually a great
signal that that's actually a crypto
friendly place
it doesn't cost them anything you know
it doesn't commit them to anything
what it does do is it puts up a flag and
if you can't get the white paper on a
government website
maybe that place isn't actually that
friendly to crypto and if you can
there's at least somebody there who's
pretty friendly to crypto it's actually
a really great
filtering mechanism in that sense it's
much more than symbolic
because of the bureaucracy involved
right it has to
actually get the nod from
quite a few stakeholders in order for
that to happen
right so it makes it would seem entirely
or could be entirely symbolic if it were
just an individual blogger for it but
for it to be put on a website like that
it signifies much more quick question
for you
again just to i mean it's just much for
me as for for people listening
what are the implications of a federal
regulatory attack
for those who are not able or not
willing to move to
miami or wyoming or the handful of
places
yeah so wyoming also by the way has
amazing crypto laws and
basically my thesis on those just to
hover on that for a second is
those places will probably litigate and
fight
some federal kind of thing if it happens
just because
they have a strong incentive to all
their citizens are there and so on and
so forth so that's actually
good because it drags it out for a long
time we see what happens
to be honest i don't know i don't know
what the answer is i think that
things are going to get really crazy
because here's the other side of it that
crypto ban if it's contemplated
will happen at the time that cryptos
created thousands of millionaires and
billionaires and thousands of
billionaires but like a lot of very
wealthy people
who are ideological these are the kind
of folks
you know the more crypto you have
typically it's more correlated with
buying into crypto in 2011 or 2012 or
2013
yeah when it was an out of the money
thing to do because you were
basically ideologically you made a bet
against
the monetary policy of the us you said
bailouts are bad and you said this is
actually despite what everybody's saying
on tv i don't believe that
i actually want to make a contrarian and
as it turns out right
bet not quote q anon or something but
contrarian and correct you know what i
mean and that's actually like the whole
teal thing you know you're actually
making something
that is in that in that quadrant and so
those folks are not
folks who are likely to just
go down without a fight you know the
whole thing these are these are
activists
and also highly highly
anti-authoritarian generally speaking
yes but but capable of organizing so not
so so it's an important combination
right the way i describe the community
actually i mean
this is the best parts of the community
there's all kinds of crazy actors in
crypto who i wouldn't endorse
but you know maybe there's an
idealization maybe this is the community
i want to build
but i think it is fair to say that the
best
tech folks and the best crypto folks are
win
and help win which is actually neither
i agree with that yeah so here's the
thing about that right that win and help
win
is neither progressive nor conservative
nor libertarian
and let me explain why okay so first
conservative you know your typical
conservative actually just you know and
maybe it's a caricature maybe some of
your listeners won't like this or
but like they just kind of want to stay
at home
you know they want to do their 95 they
want to just have
things done they're not as ambitious
they don't want to leave the small town
they don't want to go bright lights big
city that's not dispositionally small c
conservative at least
your progressive often has a very zero
sub mentality they may be ambitious
but they often believe at a very
fundamental level that
the rich are rich because the poor are
poor that one person's gain is another
person's loss necessarily and they feel
it's a zero-sum conflict and the state
you know their weapon and so on
and the libertarian will say live and
let live
which is a vision of little house on the
prairie all being by themselves etc
and win and help win is none of those
three it's ambitious
in a way that the small c conservative
is not it is positive some
in a way the progressive is not and it
is collective in a way the
libertarianism
and i think that's actually like the
most powerful kind of philosophy where
you are and notice also the ordering the
sequencing
when and help when that is to say
absolutely take care of number one
that's important because
if you don't do that you can't help
others win but do that as well
two questions for you and i'm sure many
more but
it strikes me that what francis suarez
is doing what wyoming is doing
is very valuable as an experiment and
also possibly
as different prototypes and that there
are
governors and mayors who would be very
interested in learning more about this
but they don't know how to approach it
is there a list of what these different
places are doing
estonia dubai et cetera miami
or anything a resource that one could
point
mayors and governors to who want to
possibly look at
testing different aspects of embracing
bitcoin or cryptocurrency so actually
this is one of the first 72 tasks that i
wanted to commission
because i've got a bunch of these i want
to see whether folks can crowdsource the
rest
and then we just put that into your
website so let's do this experiment i've
got like 10 or 15 of them
but i don't have i'm sure i don't have
the global list and maybe we can just
get that
second because i asked about the
probability you would assign
to the chinese side of things when you
when we were discussing that earlier
what probability would you assign to
the federal attack regulatory attack or
shutdown
in the united states a regulatory attack
of some kind
is i mean it's basically like 100
percent like in the sense of
you know like like mnuchin already tried
something
the question is what's level the attack
will be how should that factor into how
somebody thinks about
or how you might i'll make it personal
again
how would that the regulatory attack
potential factor into how you think
about
investing or not investing or bet sizing
with btc
and ethereum so the thing about this is
an
attack is not necessarily successful
that's why i say regulatory attack
and the reason is that there are
lots and lots of people across the
political spectrum who are very
pro-crypto
like pro-cryptic people tend to be more
pro-crypto than anti-crypto people or
anti-crypto
with some you know notable exceptions i
think that's true so you just feel more
passionately about it
for all kinds of reasons ideological
financial technical whatever
and they're extremely online and many of
them are crypto rich they have all the
time in the world to be extremely online
and they're extremely into establishment
and so on right so you punch massively
above their weight
this is a non-answer but let me give you
something that i think is
interesting okay back in 2011 all the
early bitcoin people thought that or not
all
a good chunk let's say on bitcoin talk
or whatever right shouldn't say all but
a good chunk of people
thought that once more people knew about
bitcoin
and crypto itself wasn't a thing it's
just bitcoin then once people more
people knew about bitcoin
well then china and russia and every
country that wasn't the us would
adopt it and the us would fight it
really hard and actually that's not what
happened
what happened was once there was money
to be made
a whole bunch of people who weren't just
interested in a purely ideological
project
but were maybe ideologically sympathetic
and could invest
came off the sidelines that's what
happened in 2013. and that was this
enormous strengthening of the ranks
that was able to make the argument that
this was financial innovation
because there was technical and monetary
upside not just an ideological project
as that actually meant that the greatest
support in some ways came from within
the us
and in fact places like china and russia
were actually more bearish
on crypto and still are than the us's in
many ways
so it was like the regime and the
opposition
are like both the strongest within it's
a hard thing for me to fully articulate
but if that makes any sense sort of like
you know but the
problem of you know the bailouts and
this
giant monetary system that's failing the
world and the solution
are both coming from within you know the
us or the west
which is this kind of crazy thing but
it's actually similar in so much to like
the three-body problem where
the chinese invite the aliens to the
world and then they have to solve
the cause you know it's like like homer
simpson like beer the cause
of and solution to all man's problems
right
[Laughter]
i was just gonna say you know it also
strikes me that your
vulnerability to regulatory
shutdown also probably
depends on the form in which you hold
bitcoin oh yeah you definitely want to
hold your keys locally
uh you know i'm an investor in a company
called casa hotel
which is actually like a rel it's a
keys.casa is url
that is it sounds oxymoronic but it's
cold storage as a service
so they go through with you how to set
up your cold storage
in such a way that like the whole
signing ceremony and so on it's
basically
home storage of your crypto in such a
way that it's hard to mess it up and
it's more error proof and whatnot
i think that you know one of the most
hardening things i've seen
since january of last year is all these
crypto leading exchanges
all around the world get your keys off
exchanges do it now
do it yesterday like get your coins off
exchanges
and uh don't worry they'll be fine
okay but you know not your keys not your
coins it's absolutely 100 true
now the thing is with defy you can't
even mess around with d5
really unless you have your keys locally
so there's an incentive as well as a
disincentive so definitely keep your
keys locally because
that at least you know means that you
can't just have your account frozen with
a tap
so we've spoken or i should say you've
spoken at length about
a number of risk factors a number of
potentials
related to bitcoin just to make sure
that we touch this base
is the risk profile of ethereum
different is it more resilient
and less susceptible to certain risks is
it more susceptible
how would you think about ethereum as
compared to bitcoin from that
perspective
yeah so it has a different pattern of
risks some of them are shared
like regulatory attacks on crypto others
are distinct
for example if ethereum completes the
migration to a proof of stake system
successfully then it doesn't have
stationary ethereum miners that can be
sort of rounded up
in the same way that bitcoin mining
farms can be so that's
you know one major major difference
where you've got a bunch of mobile
individuals
it's got downsides in other ways um i
won't get just
extreme technical detail but proof of
stake because it's not doing computation
in the same way the proof of work is
doesn't have some of the same guarantees
that prove work does in terms of being
totally totally trustless like
you sort of need someone to point you to
which chain is real there's a bunch of
chains like medusa like that are all
competing so it has a different an
overlapping set a
different an orthogonal set of wrist
modes you know
or risk factors i think ethereum is
uh certainly more complicated than
bitcoin in many ways
the most important of which being that
there's tons of programs running on top
of the ethereum itself
and all these smart contracts and it
does have actually a negative network
effect right now
where the more things that run on it the
higher the fees are which crowd out
other things
so there's both positive network effects
from composability and negative network
effects that come from just incredibly
high fees for all kinds of stuff
now everybody's working on scalability
of blockchains it's a good problem to
have
um it's kind of like scaling the early
internet there's going to be
automatically new things
an investor in something called
starkware which has something called
cairo
that is very promising and general
so-called zero-knowledge roll-ups are
very promising
it may turn out for example with
ethereum that many only the priciest
applications stay on ethereum
and many other applications go to other
l1 chains
that then all just specialize by
application i think that's
probably the most likely outcome or
rather i think ethereum will scale
but i think that you know for example
derivatives might go to a chain that's
specialized for that
nfts might go to a chain that specialize
for that and so on and so forth
and chain interoperability is so-called
interchange will be a big thing
you know where assets can be indexed in
references even if they're remote
to a particular chain you know so
bitcoin had no knowledge of other chains
but nowadays genes do have knowledge of
other genes through things like crypto
oracles or things outside of themselves
so the risk factors of ethereum are
distinct different from the those of
bitcoin
not some overlapping sub not let's segue
to
lee kuan yew and uh
we'll we'll get into who this is before
we get there maybe this will be
a shorter question and a shorter answer
but they're they're in some ways tied
together
in my mind at least there are those out
there
who are terrified of your predictions
because
they feel rightly or wrongly and i want
to hear your perspective on this
that there is a high likelihood
baked into those predictions of
apocalyptic outcomes and that
one needs to become a a tech enabled
jason bourne
to survive let alone thrive in the
future
[Music]
but go ahead
[Music]
[Laughter]
so how how would you respond to that
assessment do you view yourself as
leaning
towards viewing the future with through
the lens of
entropy and and dystopian possibilities
or is that just a misread of what you're
saying
and is that just a mystery to view in
general i
think the future will be more different
from the present than is commonly
understood
and that's actually so more different
than ours
uh like was the year 2000 that different
from 1970
not really i mean certainly there were
political changes
obviously you know china had reformed
and the ussr had fallen and so forth
but the rhythms of daily life were
actually quite similar people got up
they went to work
there was like a there's a relative
constancy there yeah there were their
phones but
they weren't smartphones they were still
basically landlines you know
headsets or handsets right cordless
perhaps
over the last 20 years there's been an
enormous change in terms of the rhythms
of daily life
one way of thinking about that is what
was your day left when you woke up in
1980
okay so you would you know there'd be an
alarm clock
you'd wake up you'd go downstairs maybe
flip on the tv to look at the morning
news
make some eggs drink some orange juice
maybe read the morning newspaper
go and drive to work where your job
involved if your white collar likes some
papers
and if you're blue collar you're going
and hammering something or whatever
you'd come back maybe go to the bar on
the way back
or you just come straight home and you
know play with your kids or
or something like that and almost every
aspect of that has now changed how do
you wake up you wake up to your phone
what's the first thing you do
you look at all of your email because
you're getting just all these
messages right messages are coming in to
you right you have this personal
communications os
it's the first thing you do is different
um this is for people who are addicted
to their phone but a lot of people are
you come downstairs or you get up and
um maybe you've got some fitness thing
that has
read off your sleep so you look at that
because your sleep was also instrumented
you know you go to the kitchen and uh
yeah there's food there
but maybe you just go straight to work
and you
uber eats you know food to work uh or
maybe you don't go to work at all
and you just work remote from your
pajamas in in
you know the living room which is
totally feasible today your job isn't
involving papers or hammering things but
it's hitting keys
everything is with 50 people who you
might have never met in person that
they're remote all around the world
through the day you're like reading
newspapers you're
reading code your job is just much more
variable
than the hammering job rather than
pushing the same button
for 20 years you're pushing a different
key every second
basically every single second of life
from your sleep to your sleep tracker
to your food through your ordering apps
or what have you
to obviously your work to your finances
to your communications to where you
decide to go after you finish working
like okay let's do google maps now the
whole map is opened up
one thing we take for granted in the 80s
and 90s when
you really had to get atlas to or you
know get a map out to go somewhere new
and you had to study
because you could get lost getting lost
was a thing never get lost anymore not
in the same way
so for the most part thoroughfares were
really important people didn't really go
off the beaten path that much unless you
had a house over there
it was like the fewest number of turns
you really didn't drive around randomly
you didn't go to like this random coffee
shop over here the map
was mostly like cornered you know it
wasn't opened up
and so that's all opened up now your
your recreational life you can meet with
a different person
rather than the same group of friends so
in so many ways the rhythms of life
we've turned into these sort of nomadic
creatures
from 20 years ago and our political
structures and our
in our homes and a lot of those are
things haven't flexed
to accommodate that and one way to think
about that
is there's two major ways that humans
operate there's like
the hunter-gatherer you know where rome
around the world
many religions many cultures have
something similar to a garden of eden
type thing which is
whether it's in our genes from you know
some primitive hominid ancestor that
we've
got all the way down because vision is
baked into the genes of course
like the reason you can recognize
something is human there's that's
genetics so maybe there's some
something coded into us from many many
millennia ago
that recognizes the garden of eden-like
thing where hunter gathers who knows how
it's represented
and and then of course there's a farmer
and the warrior right where you have a
piece of land
rather than roaming all around you're
settled in one spot
and your food is worse it's grains it
like
messes up your teeth and so on it has
you grow less but it's more reliable
it's more consistent
rather than the variable ups and downs
of that gathered and in many ways what i
think
and this is not original you know to me
by any means
fusion so this is a lot of different
ideas but perhaps at least this take on
it
is you know we're going back to the
hunter-gatherer
way of doing things but with technology
the best quality of life
will actually be available to the
digital nomad
who has a minimum number of possessions
has
the ability to pick up and move stakes
at any point has because mobility is
leveraged against the state
right a state as a sessile actor
mobility
is something that you can do as an
individual the state cannot do not as
easily
you know it can't just stretch a tendril
somewhere else so new
kinds of polities will form new ways of
self-governing humans that are
fundamentally network-based rather than
state-based fundamentally optimized for
mobile social networks
as opposed to stationary houses because
the assumptions are fundamentally
different
and you know basically for example you
know i define a network state as
a social network with an integrated
cryptocurrency and a sense of national
consciousness
that eventually crowdfunds territory
okay and i think that's a new kind of
thing that's at least one definition of
networking
that territory doesn't have to be all in
one place it can be a cul-de-sac here a
range here an apartment building here
and so you have you know a group of 100
000 people let's say that owns pieces of
territory all around the world
and that is constantly in communication
with each other through a social network
and considers themselves to be a people
it's like nation
national formation distillation that
centrifugation that we talked about out
of the internet
boom it's a network state and uh it is a
like a cloud formation taking physical
shape
you know the clouds are actually
distilling down and so
you know when i think about the future i
think about
this type of stuff where i'm just
thinking from
you know i'm thinking about 50 different
graphs this is going down this is going
up this is going down this is going up
actually jordan peterson had a good
remark on this similar
kind of train of thought where he's like
the number of different revolutions
that's happening at the same time is too
hard to track
tinder alone is a complete change in how
making happens
swipe right swipe left swipe right swipe
left that itself is like this
huge thing that would dominate the
textbooks of another age you know
because it's a massive change in how
like the daily rhythms of life operate
you went from
having like have you seen the graph of
how people meet their partners
i have not okay this is amazing graph
of like how people meet their
significant other 2020 update basically
each little curve here tells a story but
it's like did you meet at church
did you meet through your parents do you
mean a college do you mean at work
and you can see like meet at work is
like this boomlet that kind of drops off
it's peaked in the 80s and it drops off
in the 90s with you know various kinds
of pathologization of something like
that right
so what dominates everything today is
internet internet internet and in
particular
basically what norms have shifted now is
that
it's actually more legitimate i mean
like i've aged out of this
fortunately right before my younger you
know
friends would have you it is impolite to
hit often
consider depending on the situation it's
often considered impolite to hit on
somebody
in real life but it's totally okay to do
so on tinder so of course humans are
contextual and of course the same
behavior that's okay
in a in a bar is not okay in a workplace
or whatever
but now that's actually extended to
digital venues as well so gender law is
just this massive revolution
and then you have like 20 of them
happening at the same time
and so all of those are these things
where the institutions that we have are
simply not
built for this at all and that's what
they're straining and stressing against
and they're going to give
and we have to have a vision for what's
on the other side so you're more a
student of destabilization
or stabilization but it just so happens
that right now
these multiple revolutions combine
to present destabilizing forces not so
much
that you view humans or the future of
humans through a dystopian or
pessimistic lens
is that fair to say yeah that's fair to
say i think there's actually a lot of
good stuff that's going to come out of
this
i think we are going to get to so what
is a positive vision what do i think
about
you know i do think that we can shape
the future
individuals can shape the future you can
share the future a founder can share the
future i've seen it happen with my own
eyes
what i think a lot about is
a positive international vision and i
think that's going to be based around
essentially transhumanism and why do i
say that
so uh you know i've got various
one-liners on this but
i've got this book coming out by the way
that'll actually also be serialized in
1729 so like those daily tasks and book
chapters with
the book's title is the network sheet so
you've got about 10 chapters
that should be dropping and then more to
come
but one of the concepts in it is
infinite frontier
immutable money eternal life like as
something to strive for
you know because you need these sort of
slogans or things which
you know bumper sticker that expands
into a phd thesis right so what does
that say that says
space is good that says you know bitcoin
is good crypto is good
that says life extension is good and you
know that pulls so much with it
life extension basically says look
universal health care is not enough we
need eternal life
okay our ambitions have actually been
lower than they need to be
universal health care is just moving
gravy around on the plate
it's it's a fundamentally zero cent
mentality that really presumes
that's a great turn of phrase yeah yeah
the moving
moving gravy around on the plate well
like the goal is for you to not
need health care in any normal sense the
goal is for you to be this
self-repairing rejuvenating
there's technologies out there which
would sound crazy but i've got a post
called the purpose of technology
you know we can scientists can engineers
can
restore sight cure deafness there's good
research on limb regeneration
there's good research on genetic
modifications that'll make you
completely ripped
without ever having to do anything like
the folio sand and stuff and maya
and stuff and you know can i pause for
one second okay
just for just for people who don't have
this bit of context
because i i don't want i don't want
folks to think
these are the the ravings of a madman
you are very
you you are very cross-disciplinary
you've spent a lot of time
in the biological sciences genomics
computational biology of course
tell me if this is a fair statement i
mean you you almost became the head of
the fda under the last
administration as well is that a fair
statement
i was considered for a very senior role
there yes okay
that's just just wanted to add that for
for people who may not have any of that
context so
so please continue yes healthcare
universal healthcare or basic healthcare
moving graveyard on a plate
unnecessarily or unhelpfully low
expectation
right right so exactly like i'm i'm
really not somebody to stand on
qualifications or credentials or
whatever but in this area some you know
people want to check them
yes i taught computational genomics i
founded a clinical genomics company
all that stuff and uh you know of course
no one can be an expert in every area of
biology it's too big you know there's
guys who are experts in radiology which
i don't know as much about
but i do think that one of the few good
things that will come out of this
pandemic
is a white sheep recovery where we're
taking a different fork
we've deprecated the 20th century
leisure economy
you know the 20th century leisure
economy of bars and restaurants and
clubs
and all that type of stuff is something
which you know just had
this enormous economic hit to it you
know the levels of bankruptcies are just
off the charts it's a terrible thing
i think if we're lucky we get not in its
place
because it's not zero sum but there's a
greater focus on
health on life extension and we're just
gonna say life extension by the way
we're really reversing aging which is
even better is
it just captures everything right it's
like a it's like um a universal ruler
where if we can reverse aging we can fix
so many other things we can probably
should say cure cancer there's many
kinds of issues muscular
skeletal things you know osteoporosis
you know macular degeneration
all those kinds of things that happen
often they're correlated with
increasing age you know and uh and
people have this mental model that oh
we're just breaking down you know like a
car
it just accumulates hits and it breaks
down right that actually cannot be the
model
of how aging happens do you know why
why is that if that was the case if we
were breaking down like a mechanical
thing okay then there's a known skull
distribution would be like
a it's like a hazard rate right so
there's a you'd have an exponential
distribution
of lifetimes and some fraction
of cars for example just managed to make
it through without any hits whatsoever
and so you'd have like some people if
that was the case would live like a
thousand years
um because they'd just be lucky and not
take any hits at all that's not what we
see what we see is actually like a sharp
cut off
at like 120. right if you keep the if
you if you keep the human in the garage
in perfect condition they don't last
forever
they yeah exactly exactly that's right
so so there's something interesting
about it
where also you know there's this is very
predictable like there's a
an aging and then you know like there's
menopause for example and women
you know one car rolls along and it
busts a tire another one
smashed the windshield and you know like
there's a greater sphere of variability
when it's just like random things
happening
if you see 500 older men
they all are some version of grayer or
you know more wrinkled or what have you
right there's a predictability to it you
know how
actually everything's happening so
because of this people have found that
aging is actually a coordinated thing
and
people understand that going from a
child to an adolescent
is a coordinated process right you
people get that that's programmed into
your genes
what just hasn't really sunk in for many
people is that the aging part is as well
and we might be able to unprogram that
or reverse that and in fact
there's actually a lot of results in
this area way more than people think
okay there are studies i can show you
that are what we
do we technically call the holy [ __ ]
phenotype
okay where there's guy whose graying
hair
has just been reversed right
repigmentation of hair
just by taking a cancer drug as a side
effect there are
you know studies of rats you can see the
foliage and injections you get like this
hulk
rat i posted one of these um and and
so there's actually amazing things that
are happening in biomedicine
that have simply not achieved
distribution in part because of
regulation in part because
that's simply not the stories that
people are interested in telling
in part because not exactly lack of
funding but it is
lack of funding and energy sufficient to
overcome the regulatory and negative
press obstacles
you know and this is something i think
is related to kind of doing
decentralized media getting folks around
transhumanism
either people are going to kind of
vector on the sort of anarcho primitives
of access job that is
no it's a word it's afraid i think it's
going to become much more well known
and narco primitivism it's basically
like the unabomber ideology
right it is the uh essential ideology
that
humans are bad we're all destroying the
planet therefore we need to kill as many
humans as possible
or it's like you know venment voluntary
human extinction movement
okay um i don't i do not okay
this is like a quasi joke but there's
actually a lot of folks
who do on some level believe that
humanity is bad humans are bad humans
impact when the world is bad
you shouldn't have children because
they're caught everyone's causing
climate change
and we're ruining the earth and uh we
need to have a smaller footprint
and we need to shrink onto ourselves and
we can't expand and what we're doing is
terrible
and and we should just go back to nature
somehow and technology is bad
the future sucks right this is a real
attitude and it's partly connected to
folks i think idolizing nature you know
and these are folks who love nature
but often i don't think they realize
they love tamed nature
you know they they like nature without
like
wild lions they like nature while they
still have eye glasses and they like
nature while they can
decide to cut it loose that nature and
go back to a warm bed they're not
really going to live like i mean the
unibomber at least had skin in the game
you know he's out there actually living
in the wilderness like a you know like a
true caveman
but many of these folks are are they're
just inconsistent but nevertheless
they call themselves an arc of
primitivist and that's a real ideology
and it's a burn it all down ideology
right and unfortunately
it's very popular much more so than you
might think because it's easy to burn
ball down
it's exciting to do the aftermath sucks
but uh it's it is like you get the sense
of transgression
you get the sense of maybe doing it all
collectively together
you get the sense of we're making
history and destroying it sticking with
demand etc uh and against that i think
is transhumanism right where you're
going to the stars
right you're transcending this human
body right we are doing brain machine
interface
we're doing liver generation we're doing
crispr
right we're doing all the things you
know and
we're taking away all the limits that
thus
infinite frontier immutable money
eternal life let me hop in for just a
second are there any particular
thinkers scientists
or resources you would recommend just a
handful
for people who want to explore this
further i don't know if it would be
david sinclair and aubrey gray
yeah who would make your short list or
what resources
it's funny because the serious book on
tr so
zoltan is spawn is pretty good um i
think uh
and of course say that one more time
please zoltan
isfan um he's prof great
great name yeah exactly yeah um
he there's a debate that he did with an
iron caprice a while back called
his name and they built it as sultan
versus zerzon which i thought was
hilarious
it's like uh something from us from uh
from one of those early superman movies
yeah superman too zoltan versus zers and
2014
right so uh and you know this is one of
those things which i don't think people
realize is like
this obscure thing happening in academia
that is going to dominate our future
you know because they're going to be
like essentially these
for lack of term luddite forces who
don't like tech don't like the
disruption springing think
you know we we need to go back right
we need to go back to when it was a
simpler time and i understand that right
like i actually really do
the easiest way to give them that pass
is actually vr goggles so we'll give
them these
you know um i like half kid but i don't
fully kid ready player one here you go
ready player knight exactly right right
uh because that's actually
that's that's the best way to give them
the idealized version that they think
they want
this is a rabbit hole that could go very
very deep so i want to
respect the value in that while also
recognizing that we may
we may want to leave people hungry for
more of that
and continue exploring when we think of
these sort of uh
i think i'm getting this right sort of
malthusian dilemmas and
growth of population and inextricable
devastation and ecological collapse and
so on i mean i i
do think there are some arguments to be
made that uh
uncontrolled population growth is a
terrible thing
for an invasive species so successful
like human beings but that's why that's
things that's why we need
right right so we so we have the extra
planetary and then we also have
a few corrective forces if anyone has
read
lessons of history by will and ariel
durant
uh you know war famine and pestilence
uh example given covet 19 also do a
pretty good job
of correcting for a lot of that
so we were we were discussing nation
building we've talked about nation
states
the weaknesses thereof of certain types
of nation states
and different types of leadership and
that is a segue to lee kuan yew could
you please explain for people
who lee kuan yew was
and why he is interesting
lee kuan yew was probably the greatest
leader of the 20th century
he was the man who took singapore
from literally a third world he wrote a
book called from
third world to first and he took
singapore from
this third world swamp which
had all of these historical battles with
drug addiction this post-colonial
you know kind of dump into you know this
shining metropolis he had no natural
resources to work with
it was a tiny place that was surrounded
by hostile actors
he was in a region where there was a ton
of basically communist revolutionaries
that they were trying to operate because
then indochina where you had obviously
vietnam and you had
cambodia you had china you know pushing
everybody into communism
and uh and despite all of that he
managed to pilot it through not simply
to survive as a polity but
to build a country that was so
impressive
that when deng xiaoping took over china
he actually went
to talk to lee kuan yew as one of the
people to help him reform china
because you could see what an ethnically
chinese population had done there
he could also see it in taiwan and hong
kong but for various reasons
those were um you know certainly
influential in deng xiaoping
but they were uh they're also
counter-revolutionary and so he had to
give him a little bit more of a distance
whereas singapore and lky were kind of
the switzerland of southeast asia and
what lee kuan yew did really the reason
i think he's so important
is i think he's a piece of the 21st
century that fell into the 20th
you know to paraphrase basically
he was the first startup ceo of a
country
of a city state and i think we'll see a
thousand more like him
and so he's a very important person to
study his life
and history because here's the thing he
did what he did with minimal coercion
he's not famous for winning some giant
violent conflict
he's not famous for you know some like
activist
uh you know kind of movement he stands
for delivering results
that's actually really really
interesting you know he's famous for
boosting prosperity and zero to wanting
a society
and it was really a lie you know really
a great guy uh now of course there's a
lot of people who
i should say a lot of people don't like
there's a lot of people who will try to
knock down singapore
in various ways you know there's a
famous article from a long time like
disneyland or the death penalty
here's the thing part of the reason is
disneyland is it does have the death
penalty
for drug smugglers right like the thing
is singapore
and china had a huge problem with the
opium wars
or during during that period like the
british basically had addicted
huge percentages of the population to
opium and that part is often not talked
about in like that
disneyland definitely thing there's a
whole colonial overlay
on what western powers have done in that
region
and uh you basically lka might just
cleaned up that whole thing right
now i can understand that people don't
want to live there i think also like
the netherlands is a totally different
solution for example on drugs which is
total legalization
fine okay different strokes for
different folks i think you can there's
multiple solutions there
but as just a ridiculously impressive
you know country in many many different
ways from a financial center it's
becoming tech capital you know
i've got unicorns there just a very very
awesome country it's warm
i i love it great place hugely
impressive
uh lky and lee kuan yew is spelled
l-e-e-k-u-a-n-y-e-w for people who want
to learn
more about him and it is
true i mean the systematic approach with
which
that country has been transformed into
what it is today is
mind-boggling and it makes me also
all the more appreciate when i went to
princeton as an undergrad
and there were many singaporean students
all of which were going to go back to
singapore at the end because their
educations were being paid for by the
government to work for the government
and so their
their inclusion and retention of talent
inside the government is is also
remarkable and uh you know the way that
they are
they prioritize financially
incentivizing also
top talent to participate in government
i think is really
worth studying are there any other
countries
that are on your short list to watch if
there were
places that maybe
you know the 22nd century dropping into
the 21st
i'm i'm pushing the you know the
comparison a bit
yeah so estonia estonia yeah so estonia
very
so basically the countries i'm going to
name are those that have
leaders with some of the skills of
software ceos right so it's a different
approach to the network seat
where estate takes on like
qualities of like a like a tech company
you know
masters technology to drive things
forward right so estonia
basically had this guy around the time
of independence when studying god's
independence from the soviet union
was guy tumus elves who is a princeton
trained computer scientist
and he was the one who said look we need
to use this internet thing
which at the time was like you know
a country gang's independence and me
being there and saying we need to do the
scripture thing
it was definitely some people were
talking but that's that's roughly
analogous you know what i mean
it was it was a thing certainly people
were talking about but you were talking
like the
mid 90s when it was a relatively early
thing to do
you know it was not like like
uncontroversial but essentially sony
became a software country
and so they punched way above their
weight with skype and transferwise and
other kinds of companies that have come
out
really really impressive place dubai
actually
you know has done quite well they uh
they've got a large fund where they're
investing in things very lovable place
uh and very tech savvy i think uh
switzerland has
the commonality of the places that i'm
naming is that they are relatively small
countries
which have had to do more convincing
than coercing
you know when you're a gigantic country
your go-to is
course right oh i can pass a law compel
all these people etc
when you're a small country you have to
work for your supper every day
and it's actually a better habit
in the time of the internet you know
when crucially
all these people are now mobile you know
in the remote economy
the remote economy what covert has done
what most people don't understand is
doing this and then the remote economy
just jacked it up
just like google news in 2002 put every
single newspaper in competition with
every other one
and then all of these local newspapers
shuttered and only the
really big national newspapers became
international centers right the ones
that could respond to it
right and then the smart ones actually
saw that and then you had new things
come up like
you know just pure digital outlets right
in the same way
the remote economy has put every city in
competition with every other city
miami is in competition with san
francisco is in competition with this
and competition of that
and the smart cities recognize that
actually miami is
on my watch list now you know it depends
on how much strength
francis suarez has because you know he's
so-called weak mayor and this weak mayor
versus strong marriage like
his formal powers may not be that much
but his political capital is much higher
now right well i don't know
how that actually nets out okay but
estonia there's switzerland
there is dubai there's singapore
actually israel
also they've got unit 8600 they've got
very up on cyber war they you know they
they reinvent themselves constantly
taiwan with audrey tang there who has
done a phenomenal job in terms of
leading their covert response
i think let me see what else um those
are some big ones monaco the prince of
monaco is actually
very smart about crypto i think uh
you know now in terms of larger
countries i'm actually
so let's do china india u.s right uh
appreciate the big 30.
india's in the news right now quite a
bit and uh i mean you've commented on
this
but yes that's right not to skip to
india
i'll do it it's the one which i think is
going to be the dark horse of this
decade
like it's the one that's not priced in
like people just don't understand how
big a deal it's going to be
but i'll come back to that so china is
kind of priced in
i mean like everybody knows it's a big
deal it's going to continue to be a big
deal go ahead
no you keep asking me i'm just smiling
i'm just smiling
yes china china everybody knows china is
a big deal so
i think the part that is what is not
pricing about china
i think that most people don't realize
that
a lot of i mean it is definitely
becoming more totalitarian
right the xi jinping thought app and
sort of thought control is actually you
know
jack ma having what happened to him
anyway the jackpot thing made the
headlines because he's like
so big that he's known in the us for
people who don't know
jack ma founder or maybe co-founder of
alibaba
like jeff bezos of china i think would
be fair to say that's right
that's right so the super rich super
successful
tech entrepreneur gave speech that was
critical of regulation
in a fairly measured way and they just
you know like like went after him they
stopped the ipo of the alibaba ipo
he's under quasi house arrest all the
regulars so mad
and they showed him who his boss right
and that is a real
change right like you know to be a
chinese entrepreneur in china
uh the state is really asserting itself
and saying you know there shall be no
gods before me you know as an
entrepreneur you better bow and kiss the
ring you know
you know and they're also pushing much
harder on like this and being thought
app where
you have to like repeat seizures being
thought all the time and so on right
now is that that far from where america
is nowadays not that far anymore
actually
like that's the thing i don't think
people get i think the world is
splitting into three groups
which i think of as woke capital
communist capital and crypto capital and
america is vote capital in america and
its subsidiaries tributaries allies
whatever you want to call them
communist capital is china and
cryptocapital is
the free world you know and the
distinction is
the first two are very good at pointing
out each other's flaws
and faults but not in you know the the
internet censorship all that stuff is
gonna
is ramping up gonna ramp up aggressively
in the us i think that by 2024
you're going to have to use vpns there's
going to be all kinds of filtering at
the
isp level it's going to get very very
aggressive i mean that
all that stuff already exists you know
there's safe search there's block sites
and so on
but it's going to get to a level way
beyond where people think
because east coast institutions can no
longer win a game of free speech
and free markets so they're going to
restrict and constrict
and obviously the same thing is
happening in china the difference is 10
is just more like
more explicit about it which is both
good and bad it is good
in the sense that everyone can identify
it's happening
right it's obviously bad because when
it's explicit they're just
in your face about it the site is up and
then it's down and there's no
apology that is given it's just the
government says so
right in the u.s it's this weird
moonwalk
where you know it's more like the soviet
union where the soviet union would
say that you have this great
constitution
and hey everyone can have an election
and so on and so forth right
but then actually i don't know if you
know how elections worked in the soviet
union
you could just put in a blank ballot to
vote for the communists but if you want
to vote for someone else you could do it
you got you'd write something down and
then kind of know who you were you know
and so on right
and so you had all these rights
guaranteed on paper but
the actuality of it was a completely
different thing you know the gap between
the actual thing and what was written
down and that's where the u.s is
becoming
where it is you know there's this joke
in the 1980s that'll kind of illustrate
it you know the
guy jakob smearing off i know if you
remember him he said something like um
his joker came over from russia he's
like oh people say that
you know in russia we don't have freedom
of speech of course we have freedom of
speech
but in america you also have freedom
after speech
that's great yeah that's good right is
that true anymore not really
right not really you know or at least
not not outside of pseudonym
so what i think is you know i think
china is actually underestimated in some
ways it's not fully pricing i think a
lot of americans
underestimate china for a few reasons
first is they think everybody within the
country
is like this oppressed that they they
don't like the regime
you know they're against regime i think
if you're a uyghur
or you're jack ma or you're an
entrepreneur is on the wrong side of the
communist party
yeah you're probably not a fan but i
think that on net the chinese government
has delivered the goods
with the for many people from their
perception with the covered response and
like 40 years of growth and they're the
relative winners of coke like the west
just
totally wrecked themselves right and
technologically they're
way beyond people don't understand how
how far beyond they are like
they did like drones for taking people
temperatures
you know i tweeted about this in the
early days of covet they really did like
five years in like a few months
of technological improvements still from
like robots delivering stuff you know
they had hospitals they were fully
telemedical hospitals
but the doctors didn't have to go in and
they could remotely operate them
all kinds of crazy things that they
managed to pull off
so it's you've heard the term cope cope
as in c-o-p-e
yeah well so like it's it's usually and
i know the word
you know the word right but online it's
used as
you know yo man that's cope right you're
just you're saying that to try to handle
this difficult situation
right and there's a lot of folks who are
over the course of covet i saw something
very new
and interesting i mean bad but
interesting happen which was
as the u.s sort of flailed in its
response you know
as uh the federal government failed and
state governments failed and local
governments failed as
public health failed and public schools
failed and police failed and fire failed
you know as the power went out as the
health went out
you know um as like riots had all this
stuff happened right
people would basically say things like
oh yeah
you know i know you're saying taiwan's
gotten under control but
they're an island and you know like new
zealand oh yeah well
janet they're totalitarian and everyone
would give like this litany of excuses
which was why now of course you're so
stupid that that wouldn't possibly apply
to the us
and fundamentally it was basically a
bunch of excuses where yeah
america isn't the worst in the world
what are you saying we're just as bad as
europe
you know they kind of make these kinds
of comparisons you know and
you know you have to [ __ ] your hair and
be like we're number one usa usa usa
is just extremely different from yeah
we're not the worst
just completely different right and
while there's this cope within the us
on this outside it's very perceptible
that the us was basically like it was
just handed like a military defeat by
covet
people don't actually fully perceive
this but like you know i mentioned this
you know a few times on twitter it just
hasn't sunk in or you know whatever
maybe
people will get mad at me but 2018 there
was a dod
thing that was something like national
biodefense
policy uh defense strategy protects
against
man-made and uh national threats
and all of these you know four-star this
and that foo for us
oh we're so protected and they've got
like this plan
and they've they've had billions of
dollars that was allocated for
biodefense since anthrax attacks
in 2001 2002 right i think it was 2001.
i forgot
it was late 2001 or early 2002 but i
think it's late 2001 right after 911.
since anthrax was getting all this money
that went to biodefense i know because
when i was in grad school a lot of that
money was flying around for like
microbial research and what have you
that was like 15 years ago and uh you
know there were stars
and there was the ebola scare there's
plenty of warnings for all of this
right and it was a military priority
there was like darpa stuff that was
supposed to crank out fast vaccines
and none of it actually seemed to work
right like basically the to the best of
my knowledge and correct me if i'm wrong
i might be wrong
the military's most public thing was
setting up the folding chairs in the
java center
and that sounds really harsh you know
what i'm talking about right the
palliative care
they're early independence i do right i
do yeah and they put like a flower there
so people could like die next to a
flower okay that
sucks and the reason i kind of make that
harsh
you know comparison is um
you know the maginot line in world war
one i do not okay i do not and also
i know we have the lens on the us right
now within the context of china but i
would love to
uh make sure we don't forget to
have you comment on the other things
that are not fully appreciated about
china but yes
just continue and i don't know the line
i i don't i don't know the line that
you're referring to in world war ii oh
okay so after world war one
the french built something called the
maginot line which was like oh yeah
germans you're gonna try trench warfare
on us we're building the system of
fortifications where we'll
just gun you the f down and you'll never
win trench warfare against us again
right of course germans invented
blitzkrieg and just went around it
right so the huge system of
fortifications so it's a great metaphor
for fighting the last four
right and so you know there's like
there's a guy who i i don't personally
beat for the right thing i've never met
him or anything
this guy who a lot of you know folks
quote like zion and i should probably go
and write a blog post on
all the things i disagree with there's
about 20 i agree with like
it's true that shale oil is an important
resource for the us but
you know he thinks for example american
or or demographics are a big win for the
u.s over china but
robotics over demographics you need a
small number of people programming
robots that's the future
you know you can already see that in
warehouses another thing is
he's like really bullish on like the us
military and the u.s military
like f-35 was a failure right the u.s
military just failed on the pandemic
this military in many ways i would argue
is actually imagine a line
where it's set up to fight the last four
and
you know one way of thinking about that
this is it's hard to test this
okay because you know it's just a
prediction it's a forecast
but china was able to build a hospital
in like 10 days
and their infrastructure in general you
know they can snap together a subway
in like nine hours you know i've been
posting these videos on on twitter it's
like crazy but they do they
prefab everything they stamp together on
site okay and that's something which is
a whole of society thing it has to be
legal to do that
the engineers have to be willing to work
24 hours
you know that times like that the early
american 1900s work ethic not the
late american current work ethic you
know they have to be
interested in building things as a
society you know where it's not like
everybody fighting each other where you
build something and
they'll make my property less expensive
it'll be shadows or something you know
like which is the san francisco style
all these things have to come together
it's not just one thing but they snap
together uh association in nine hours so
you can stamp together
a skyscraper in 30 days then people will
say oh yeah
well their building quality is terrible
it's all gonna fall over or whatever
right like
have you seen the millennium tower in
san francisco it's actually
creaking to one side you know the whole
sales force
complex that they built in your sales
force like this new train station that
was also cranking it was built like a
billion dollars or something like that
it was like
creaking after the first few weeks and
they had to like
not allow anybody in there right so it's
not like the american building quality i
mean this
you know it's you have to use cisco
analysis of course to actually put them
side by side
but in general if you go to china most
of the buildings are standing up
and most of them are new and they've
been built over the last you know 23
years
what's my point the point is the chinese
have shown the ability under duress
to be able to execute in the physical
world as a subroutine you can think
okay we're going to build a hospital
that's just not something we can
contemplate in the us that seems like a
30-year process
not a 10-day process right what do you
have to do in a war you have to build
like a field hospital
right you might have to build a bridge
you have to take data bridge there's all
those kinds of things that have to
happen
and if in like perhaps the most
desperate crisis the u.s has faced in a
long time you know people have this idea
that it's like uh like cramming for a
test
like we'll pull it out you know the u.s
will do the right thing after exhausting
everything else it'll quote this like
churchillisms from like
70 years ago and the thing is that
cramming for the test only works if
you've like studied someone
not if you're if you haven't done
anything for years
right and that's actually i think
it's flipped over a card where in an
actual like serious like military
conflict between the us and china
a non-nuclear conflict i think china
would probably win that's like a taiwan
conflict
because we've got all the observables
right the observables are even under
duress
the us military can't execute in the
physical world it's got these plans for
a pandemic that didn't work
the chinese can actually execute in the
physical world and build these things
and that's not just what one-off it's
like across your whole society
it's also not a one-off for the
americans across our whole society
where the power is going out and other
kinds of infrastructure things are
happening
and it's not like just one localized
place it's like the water in flint it's
a power in california
it's a power in texas it seems to be
spreading i was just going to ask
so if there were a military conflict
or a nation state versus nation-state
conflict between the u.s
and china it seems unlikely that it
would be like
red dawn on u.s soil seems unlikely not
impossible i mean there might be
a cyber attack that has impact
on any number of things in the united
states in the domestic u.s
continental us but if we take as an
example
taiwan if there were a conflict over
taiwan and the u.s
lost what are the consequences of that
in your mind
i think it's huge because i think it
basically
it'd be comparable to like the russell
japanese war and
like uh in 1905 russell japanese were
actually led to like all of these former
colonial
colonized people being like whoa wait a
second the
non-whites can win against white's holy
cow right and
it was this huge mental unblock where
that led to anti-colonial sentiment and
so on just kind of ended one century and
began another
and i think it would that would be the
true end of the american empire
i think it wouldn't be something that
someone could write off like
you know oh vietnam we didn't really try
or you know oh afghanistan or iraq well
you know no one else visibly won you
know it's it's it would feel different
i think it would be like the mike tyson
getting knocked out by buster douglas
moment for the united states where
people were like oh
this is a defeatable enemy that's right
now the thing about it is
uh we should hope it doesn't come to
that what i
fear is that you know often there's a
delayed reaction or a fuse on this stuff
like occupy wall street only happened
about like three years after the
financial crisis
so the fear is that if vaccines are
eventually
rolled out and if enough americans take
them
then by 2023 or 2024
people will be spoiling for a fight to
go and beat up china as
one legitimated enemy in sort of the
same ways in the mid 2000s it was like
okay to hate you know people in the
middle east right it was like
that was like a loosen you know kind of
valve or whatever like you could be
more angry towards them it was like more
socially legitimate
i don't think it was good i think that
that was it was just true that that was
that was
more legitimate than or at least people
would greenlit more
in the same way i think anti-chinese
sentiment
will be more dreamlit people won't jump
on you
for saying things that are negative
about china it'll
filter into unfortunately many chinese
americans
because anybody who's like working at a
university lab
or something like that they'll come up
with some rationale for
why it's not racist or whatever because
it's nationalist and oh my god i can't
believe you're saying that the agents of
a totalitarian dictatorship
are blah blah blah that you have to be
concerned about but point is
that they will um i don't think it'd be
great to be a chinese american
in like four years or five years as as
the new cold war really heats up
now we should hope that doesn't actually
come to i call that a
this is one of my like bad predictions
or right it would be an unfortunate
thing
many chinese of course many chinese
americans have been here for generations
right they have no ancestral connection
or the ancestral connection
is very distant i shouldn't say it
doesn't matter it does matter like i
don't think they're going to be
stripped of citizenship or anything like
the japanese internment but i do think
that
it'll sort of be like being a muslim
american
in the 2000s basically there was
actually it's one of those things where
there was a lot of surveillance in
mosques
folks within the community felt it a lot
you might say it's legitimate events
it's not i'm not trying to get into
whether it's good or bad
i'm just saying that that's likely to
happen okay so
what's my point point is that i think
that cold war
between the us and china we should hope
it doesn't kick off into a hot one
if it does kick off into a hot one then
the wounded american pride might
like retaliate with nukes crazy things
that can happen it gets really bad
very quickly if you think about those
scenarios with that
said i think that most of the world will
actually not want to be
they want to try to keep as far away
from this fight as possible i don't
think many americans realize that many
americans think
oh yeah europe they're going to saddle
up with us against china europeans don't
think that
europeans think america has gone crazy
and europe is actually
in in many ways uh now in some ways
actually to the right of the us
you know you can actually kind of put it
on a spectrum where
the us is on this is the most left-wing
large country in the world
then you've got crypto in the center
then you've got like india and israel
like center right
and then you've got like china as like
the farthest right that's like a new
kind of political spectrum
of roughly you know on one side
ethnonationalist
on the other side ethnomassachusetts and
in the center pseudonymous
okay if that makes any sense it does let
me let me jump in for a second here and
then i want to move to the dark horse
because i know it'll probably not be a
short
short conversation on the chinese
front considering china if there were
just a few actions
or a few investments or changes that the
us military could make or the u.s
government what would they be to try to
mitigate against some of these risks
the us has within it the capability like
we're talking about earlier with crypto
beer the solution is the pro the cause
of the solution to all
man's problems and so on right the us
has within it that capability
for a rebirth just like frankly china
had a rebirth under deng xiaoping and
india had a rebirth under manmohan singh
after decades of just being in in
you know the toilet the us would have to
experience a national rebirth and
uh that's a that's a that's a serious
thing you know that's a big deal
they have to be at the like the level of
dang
or sing or leak on you or or something
at that level you'd know it when you saw
it and what kinds of things could lead
to that
let me give you some out of left field
thoughts to answer your question
do you think there's like a tweak or
another tweak no i don't think there's
any tweak because
i think the us is on a civilizational
downtrend
you know for example intel filled their
chip tape out and
lockheed martin as mentioned at 35 and
boeing failed their thing
and all physical businesses have been
shut down the only thing that basically
is functional
if you think about it are the internet
businesses that were founded 20
something years ago
there's only things that essentially
like function through the pandemic the
political institutions didn't work
right and the reason is those new
businesses
were new enough that it gets to like a
fundamental distinction i have which is
between
founding versus inheriting if the
founders are still around
the founders can edit things and change
things whereas so many of these east
coast institutions were inherited
sometimes the literal sense of inherited
fortunes
or inherited newspapers or inherited
money but also
in the sense of inherited something that
they couldn't have built in the first
place
you know the 57th mayor or you know 72nd
governor
of some state could never have organized
the
national guard and the public health
department from scratch
right they were selected solely for
legitimacy and not for competence as
well
right like if you're elected you're
selected only for legitimacy you're not
actually selected for
being able to organize the nypd from
scratch by contrast if you're a founder
you're selected for both legitimacy why
is the guy the ceo because he founded it
right so you're selected for legitimacy
but you're also selected for confidence
because
all the backlinks the support that come
into you you don't just get them
a little bit of snap overnight like you
do when you win an election
they come to you gradually over time
with a thousand proof points
you know zuckerberg didn't just get
three billion people in this gigantic
organization
there were a thousand proof points that
he did over ten years where
the support came in gradually it wasn't
just okay i don't have the nuclear codes
boom i have the nuclear cuts
right it wasn't like this overnight
thing it was gradual and
crucially one of the things about that
is the folks who were selected
on the basis of founding rather than
inheriting selected for both legitimacy
and competence rather than just
legitimacy uh those folks actually are
folks like bezos who
actually could organize the nypd or the
us military because he's an expert in
logistics and
you know i'm saying right amateurs talk
strategy professional stuff logistics
i think i have no question that business
would at least be an extremely important
contributor to the organization of a
military from scratch right
if business had to do the us military
from scratch like a drone army
he could probably do it so the question
is how do you have
selection for legitimacy and confidence
how does how do you get more founding
dna versus inheriting dna
so let me just throw a few interesting
concepts out there one thing i think
about a lot this is a chapter in my
upcoming book
is 100 democracy versus 51 democracy
so what's 51 democracy did you have a
fosbury flop is
i do i do this one i actually do you
want to explain it for folks
oh yeah dick fosbury yeah great story
that's right so basically
if you've ever seen a pole vault in the
olympics you know what a fosbury flop is
it's essentially someone
they vault in such a way that they just
barely clear the bar
they like manipulate their body in such
a way and they do it backwards yeah
they do it back first they do backwards
right so it's just like barely clearing
the bar
and that is the way a 51 democracy works
where if you think about the root of
democracy it's not actually
voting per se the fruit of democracy is
the consent of the government
right that's what makes a democracy
legitimate can i add a note on the
foster flop
uh so quick note on the phosphory flop
and dick fosbury is that
for the vast majority of the time that
the olympics have existed
the techniques used for clearing that
pole vault bar were
almost like a not a scissor kick
necessarily but
but very similar to the way you might
clear the high hurdles
in a sprint race and then dick fosbury
comes along
and i think i want to say it was in
mexico city but i i might be
misremembering that
that's right and he and the the
equipment had changed
so it became possible for the first time
to
land in the way that he landed which was
on his back
and he was ridiculed at the time ended
up winning a gold medal and now that is
the
default technique right so fosbury's
method was actually
a smart pack of the system right but one
of the things about it is basically
or the part that i'm evoking is the
feeling of just
barely clearing the bar very little
margin of safety very little margin of
safety
and so insofar as you know the
legitimacy of democracy comes from the
consent of the government
we kind of intuit that there's more
legitimacy if there's a landslide
you know there's there's like more of a
mandate you know if it's a bigger
margin right because you have more
consent if there's more consent
you need to use less coercion right you
have more of a mandate with which cigar
right 60 40 is way better than 51.49
here's the issue the issue is when it's
51.49 which has been for a long time now
basically that's just the minimum
necessary that's a fosbury flop of
consent
it's a minimum consent to say okay we've
got the consent of the government
we get the minimum necessary consent you
have to use a ton of coercion when
you're in power
and then what that does is it pushes
that two percent over to the other side
or whatever
and then the next group is in power and
then that guy has to use a lot of
coercion when they're in power
you know and so this is a very bad
negative feedback cycle where you're
using yes you can use coercion if you're
a government
but in general think about being ceo if
any of your
followers crc like a lot of people have
this kind of fantasy model of asia where
the guy goes and boxers like i'm just
true just go do it you know like that
right
and if you ever rco you'll find that
that really doesn't work you know you
have to
persuade and you have to convince and
you need to motivate
and you really can't just order flunkies
around
in quite that way because everybody's
got another possible job they can get
it's more like a you know a bunch of
subatomic particles you're holding in
your hand to just like not have them
all go escape right so it's a very
different
kind of thing where you have to convince
you can't really coerce
i'm not saying that you sometimes can't
like have to give it like an
order or something like yes we're going
to do it this way i'm not saying that
doesn't happen
but ultimately you know it is much much
more weighted towards convincing that
coercion right okay
so this is also true for a good leader a
good leader is
doing more convincing than course here's
the point we see this 5149 thing
the ideal would be a hundred zero the
idea would be 100 democracy where
everybody can sense
and to do that in such a way that's not
like some stalinist joke
where everyone's voting their great
consent for the great leader and they
don't actually have a say right
you need to have them not manufacture
consent but demonstrate a consent
right to paraphrase chomsky saying
manufacture them you want to demonstrate
consent
so where i go with that is i think okay
there's actually three kinds of votes
we think of two kinds voting with ballot
and voting with pollen which are
democracy capitalism respectively
there's a third crime which is voting
with feet namely migration
actually all three are components of the
us political system
so for example um if you put them on an
axis
right with x-axis being the cost of that
particular kind of vote and the y-axis
being the probability of changing the
outcome
but with your ballot it's a tiny tiny
small cost it's like a few hours
and a tiny probability of changing the
outcome like one over n
of n people right roughly if you vote
with your wallet
like a political donation you know it's
it's not considered
kosher to really calculate this out that
people do
washington post often publishes like the
price of a vote or whatever they
calculate okay
here's the spending of political ads
whose extra votes there's ways that
people try to pull us out of regressions
main thing is with some money you can
effectively
get more votes than just your one right
vote with your wallet it does
through ads or what have you campaign
stuff it gets you
you know you put in your 2300 max if
you're an individual it might get you 10
votes or 100 i don't know the number but
basically it'll get you more than one
okay towards a second so that is a
higher cost than a few hours
but it's a somewhat higher probability
still small of changing the law under
which you live
and then we get to migration now
migration is the highest cost of all
usually because it's like 10 000 or more
to pick up stakes and move
city to city or country to country but
it has
by far the highest probability of
changing balcony
it's 100 you just picked the loss right
you just looked at the
dashboard of all the laws and you pick
the ones you want and you move there the
vote how you want
we move over it like so once you start
thinking about like this third
fundamental force
you know there's nothing more american i
mean every america is a nation of
immigrants that means tautologically
it's also a nation of
immigrants and the camera is not
as frequently put on what causes people
to leave cause people believe was
declining economic circumstances or
communism
or civil war or socialism or just a bad
economic lack of
opportunity and they came over to the us
if our ancestors weren't evil
then immigration can't be evil in fact
immigration is the most american thing
ever
and so now when you think about that as
a third fundamental force you start
thinking
okay 100 democracy means that people are
resigning a social smart contract
every few years they're part of a polity
and
they are if they don't like it they've
got 999 other jurisdictions to go to
they can vote with their feet to go over
the critical thing this does
is this model of lots of jurisdictions
run by
ceos of city-states maximizes consent
i've got a mathematical model of this
but it maximizes consent because
like a company nobody is there as they
don't want to be
so let's let's take this opportunity to
transition
unless there are just any any closing
comments on that chapter that you'd like
to make but i
i would love to as our last topic
so once you start kind of thinking in
this way you know about like maximizing
consent and so on or using the network
versus state
something that is possible for example
in
austin you know it's a city of like 850
000
ish 1.2 million somewhere in that range
of people right
it's not inconceivable to just if you
start thinking of okay convincing rather
than chorusing
you just start by declaring yourself
shadow not you but someone maybe you
okay
someone with some distribution or even
someone wants to build it
declares themselves either shadow mirror
of austin
or community organizer or something like
that
very very different proclamations
but yes yes the shadow mirror is like
this concept like from the uk like the
shadow government right
and you just start organizing people
whether it's austin or some other city
you start organizing people it's just
like you know you start a company you
declare yourself ceo you and who
right like you're you know you're the
ceo right you named yourself ceo right
okay so you just you know whatever title
you said to give it maybe you say
lead community organizer i don't know
and people just start folding into you
if you start delivering the goods what
are the goods
i think you would conceive of this thing
as like a network union
let's say not like a normal social
network but a social tree
right not everybody connected to
higgledy piggly but a graph
where folks are folding up into like a
union leader effectively a network union
later
except it be a network union so it's not
just focus on labor rights
but it could collectively bargain on
behalf of the people as consumers
as producers as investors as voters
whatever right it's just like a group of
folks that are organized for collective
action
it could organize for example uh
shoveling of snow
or you know when power is out it's a
genuine community organization
and you have this head and these folks
folding into them what's my point
just like a startup you can grow that
and you might go back in time because
this is so new
it's actually old what i'm talking about
is old but it's it's new to us today
because it hasn't been done in a while
it doesn't seem like something you would
do people know how to start a company
in a multi-billion dollar business they
don't have a community organization but
your ancestors did it and you know like
an elks club
or whatever type thing so you build that
up and you
you know you may name it something you
start accumulating
users 10 100 1 000 10 000
because your organization is competent
and able to deliver the goods locally
it doesn't have guns it can't coerce it
doesn't have
you know guys with badges it can't tax
it has to do everything with
contributions maybe it's selling a
product maybe it's organized like a
company there's many different ways of
doing it
but fundamentally it's delivering the
social goods
that the current elected inherited
government
can't because that inherited government
was set up for a different time under a
different set of circumstances
right as you start just delivering more
goods
you gain more political capital and
ultimately that entire
social structure is just softer in
people's heads
the mayor the supervisors city hall
all that is just stuff people have
agreed to do
and just like fiat cryptocurrency call
that fiat government this is crypto
government or something like that you
know it might do it all
anonymously or whatever for some time
there's lots of different ways and
parameters you can fix
at a certain point when you've got 100
000 people in this hierarchical
organization
then yeah when there's an election
called you'll probably just instantly
win
and become mayor right and this is a way
that you can
affect political change outside of
politics
because you start actually focusing on
delivering the societal goods
by convincing people and you set
coercion to zero
and frankly you can get really far with
that because ceos get really far with
that
right you might think of this as a tech
startup you know that's a fine way of
thinking about it and you modify it to
make it like a community oriented text
there might be dues you could do
subscriptions there's lots of different
ways
you can make this work right it's a
community organization where you pay in
to get something out
that might just right there that might
work right it's got local news
it's got child care you know it's like
round robin child care you keep track
and you give to get
there's a lot of things you can do here
once you start thinking about this right
you can use facebook groups to organize
it you don't need to code things at the
beginning
a lot of it is just you might be able to
do with no code if you know that right
this is i think the recipe for how you
start rebuilding functional
organizations in the us
not trying to jam a square peg into a
round hole and be like
hey let me capture the course of state
and get the guns and then i'll be able
to finally do something embossing around
the other 49
instead you build these convince
oriented organizations as opposed to
coursework
well i might just call this maybe this
episode should be titled
the episode that's that shall spawn a
thousand
shadow mayors i think this is a valuable
discussion
i think this is a very valuable
discussion i'm glad that
you got to explain this and i would love
to get to india
yes sure let's add any sort of
concluding
statements just to that piece and then
segway
if you're open to it to maybe starting
with
india the dark horse as you mentioned
and what is currently at stake
and there may be many things at stake
but certainly the one that is pinned at
the top of your
twitter profile is of interest to me so
i'll let you take it from there
all right so we talked about china we
talked about the us
and so you have this thing where you
have this ascending china
and you have this declining u.s and
they're just on
a collision course sparks are already
flying this is the
city's trap of the rising power and the
declining one and
big fight right and there is an
interesting possible
way out of this or at least i'm not sure
there's a way out for the us and china
but there might be a way out for the
rest of the world
especially some places like india which
is india's number three
so it's neither the us or china is
actually in its own way
in the position of a singapore for
example where
it is not realistic you might think it's
realistic to course the world to use the
dollar
you might also think it's realistic of
course a big chunk of the world to use
the digital yuan
you know both of those like are
contenders for a global reserve currency
the digital rupee is not for because
it's number three you'd have to beat out
the number number one number two
so you could do something different you
could say actually
the other possibility here if you're
neither windows nor osx
you go all in on linux so you're neither
the dollar
or the renminbi you go all in on btc and
crypto
because that is because as a nation of
course
you know your first thing is you want to
be able to control your currency
but internationally you want no one to
be able to control your currency
and you'd rather have no one control it
than a foreign power controller
because the currency is not just
currency it's a technology platform
right swift you know the the
international virus that's the
technology platform the us can hit a
button and just de-platform you from
swift just like
twitter can deploy from you from twitter
the dollar is not just currency's
technology
platform and it's a declining technology
platform because
it's basically based on this 20th
century technology if you look at
the i retweeted this the other day but
china has been gradually over the last
10 years replacing the dollar
in cross-border trade it was basically
87 in 2011
and now it's it's i think it's now less
than or close to less than 50
so it's about to flip the flipping is
happening right then i'll just replace
it completely and it'll be dollar
independent
and that means just like the bit
licensing that we mentioned earlier
they'll come a day just like new york
tried to throw its weight around bit
license and actually found that it just
sanctioned itself
and rather than forcing a bunch of
companies to jump through the tubes
those companies just put it last
in the list the america will try to
wield the dollar's weapon one more time
and just find that it's actually just
owned itself you know it just walled
itself off from
enough of the world economies outside
the dollar economy is
india at risk of doing that right now so
india is
had postulated a crypto ban okay
i think that if you look at the very
latest reports um that is now being
recalled
and the reason for that is a lot of tech
people a lot of financiers a lot of
people in the government
have communicated that actually the two
biggest stories
in india over the last 30 years are a
economic liberalization and b the
internet
and crypto combines both it is the
financial internet
it's literally at that level you know
because what did the internet do
digitized
books movies songs all forms of media
right crypto goes and digitizes
everything scarce
stocks bonds commodities and of course
gold and other things
basically because what a blockchain is
potential is a way to copy things from
point a to point b
a blockchain is a way to transfer things
scarce things in a proven way
so every financial asset becomes
natively digital just like every media
thing became natively digital
so economic liberalization the internet
massively benefited india and
encrypt as a combination of them and so
banning would be this huge own goal so i
wrote a couple of long articles on this
a why india should buy bitcoin and b
how india legalizes crypto and those
have gotten a fair amount of traction
i think within the indian discussion and
there's some really good follow-up
articles and videos that i've been
retweeting
and it is it's definitely something now
where i think
folks are realizing that a ban would be
precipitate
you know it'd be it'd be too hasty um
we'll see what happens
but i think that it's going to be more
likely that it's legalized with some
form of regulation than it is to be
banned
knock on wood that's how it looks as of
right now what would be the global
consequences
of india banning cryptocurrency
so global consequences wouldn't wouldn't
actually be more
would be felt would be it's like boss
you have seen it unseen
the thing is that if india manuscript of
people don't understand how big a deal
it is in the event of krypton
because crypto hasn't had time to
compound within india
it got banned in 2018 and been unbanked
and so because of that like the crypto
industry is in a much more nascent state
than it is in other places
and so on meaning like only like 10
million people have it
or something like that which is small
for a relatively large country let me
describe what would happen
in the alternative and then it'll be
more obvious as to why it's a big deal
basically over the last four years while
everybody
you know in the west was obsessed with
like american politics or whatever
india has brought about 400 million
people online with something called
reliance geo
which basically 4g lte there is about
100 x cheaper than in the us so it has
like
the cheapest mobile lt service in the
world which is insane right because
that's a huge
physical infrastructure project in india
you know that's hard to do
you need reliable power all kinds of
things have to work for something like
that to work
and at the same time two other things
happened
covet happened so all the world's jobs
went remote
and crypto happened which meant that you
have this peer-to-peer international
payment
so india has opportunity to have
400 million people suddenly start doing
all these remote work jobs they're newly
qualified for
with their phones okay like because
every remote work job can now be done
there
which is at least i don't know 10
million 20 million 30 million
new sources of remittances and remote
work maybe it's like 10x that
who knows so that would completely
change the world
it would basically mean that every
indian who could do
white collar work could do it for 110
the price
on an android phone you know being paid
in crypto or something like that and i
might say
crypto i don't necessarily mean bitcoin
or ethereum but that's also possible
if you look at stablecoinstats.com one
of the stablecoins
which you can now zip transmit anywhere
you know that has an internet connection
just over
with all the users ethereum address you
can send it to them right with some fees
so the magnitude of that disruption is
hard to actually i mean
you know when you have like a few
hundred million people
coming online uh that's a very big deal
it is they're part of the global labor
market
i mean it's not like they wouldn't be
connected if uh they didn't have crypto
but they'd be a lot less connected
because crypto means anyone on the
internet can pay anyone to first order
right it's like email you know so if you
have to go through the repeat it's fine
for some purposes
but it's certainly not fine for just
paying somebody 20 bucks to do something
right now
you know that's like a multi-day wait
for an international wire transfer you
spend more than that on the wire fees
it just won't work so banning crypto
would be one of those things where it's
more obvious this would be lost
when we unban crypto so by 2030 you'll
be like yeah okay that whole thing
wouldn't have happened without it but
it's hard for me to show you that yet
because
compounding isn't happening right but
with distribution with wider
distribution and use
of say micro payments via cryptocurrency
much of the friction for this type
of gigantic
possible workforce to engage globally is
removed
right a lot of the friction it put
another way exactly if the indian
government wants to facilitate the
global participation
and effective competition of its
citizens we're going to come
online on mass with
profound implications than
cryptocurrency
facilitates that substantially that's
right i mean india basically
is internationally competitive in
computer science
and it's also pretty good at all
these i mean like the indian diaspora
has been pretty good at things like
finance media journalism
you know as mentioned engineering but
also medicine you know and so forth
right
it's notable in those areas these are
all like white-collar jobs
that you could do over an internet
connection
for crypto and then you wouldn't even
have to leave india and remittances
remote work are a huge source of revenue
so basically india could be this the
only thing about it by the way
by supporting crypto right now you know
america is blowing up the middle east
and china is building colonies in africa
and you know like
like actually on net yes built those
colonies for everybody called galilees
you call them cities
the africans actually are benefiting
from the chinese presence in that sense
they're actually getting infrastructure
and so on out of it if you actually talk
to africans there
they're not that negative on them it's
it's definitely not like oh we hate the
chinese or something it's not like that
right
but people can say like oh you know the
chinese are actually hooking them today
and then they're going to put them in
debt you know like they're trying to do
with the belt and road projects are you
ready
are you you're familiar with that no i
mean they're excited okay
depend i'm sure some of them okay but
i'm not so china has this thing called
the belton road
which um was a bigger deal before the
pandemic but they may be rebooting it
essentially it's this idea of building
global trade routes both overland and
overseas
where china builds across eurasia these
huge railway lines they can ship their
finished goods everywhere to hit all
these markets
one of the concepts behind the belton
road is china builds infrastructure in
all these countries of ports
and railway stations and fueling
stations and all this stuff schools
whatever
and return that government just takes
out a loan in renminbi but maybe it
can't pay back in which case
china kind of repos everything and has a
military base there or whatever right
so that's kind of this heads i win tails
that don't lose deal
but that china is doing it's actually
quite smart it's kind of like the
marshall plan
in a different way you know where the
u.s got all these military bases you
know right uh that's a simple way of
looking at it of course but
you know that's certainly part of the
game is for the us to have military
presence in western europe
what's the point point is while america
is blowing things up and
while china is building these colonies
what india could do is build software
for the world
because getting behind crypto and this
is a good case right if india gets
behind crypto
crypto is a globally neutral platform
because everybody can trust it since
they don't need to trust
they can audit it right they can look at
it themselves i already see this today
by the way
you know chinese people no longer trust
the or trains investors don't trust the
us legal system and certainly not vice
versa
but both them will definitely invest in
a smart contract on ethereum
that's actually where international
capitalism still lives and will continue
to thrive
even in this age of tariffs and trade
war and so on and so forth people can
actually work across borders
regardless of facility fights this is
actually my spirit
and this is something which i think
india can be
kind of a peacemaker similar to actually
in some ways they tried to stay out of
the cold war with the so-called
non-alignment you know there was
nato and the warsaw pact and the
non-alignment the line movement
was it was sympathetic to the soviet
union but it wasn't sending troops
around the world to wage communist
revolution
that was actually origin of the term
third world you know first world was
the west second world war the communist
countries in the third world where all
these
you know countries are behind the
non-alignment now of course the online
movement
came in third it was poor they didn't
have part of the reasons didn't
join any militaries didn't have the
money to even pay for the guns or
anything like that right
but now back to the future i think if
the us
and the west is you know there's a
declining west
and it's vote capital and uh you have on
the other side
you know the chinese our communist
capital i think india could be crypto
capital
and it could be the center of the
decentralized movement
which is maybe the most powerful of the
three
because they're sympathizers of crypto
in both the us and china
millions of people and the it sounds
weird to put it that way
today in 2020 but it won't sound that
weird in 2025 or 2030
because crypt is an ideological movement
and it's a transnational movement it's
international capitalist
and it's not nationalist capitalists
like reagan it's
not nationalist socialist or
international socialists like uh
hillary stalin's national socialist or
lenin's international socialists it's
internationalist and capitalist
right and our atrocity was
internationalist and socialist
so international and capitalist is like
tech that's crypto
that is do a deal across borders that is
i don't care what you look like you know
we're equal partners in the deal and of
course there's bad aspects of it too i'm
sure people can rattle them off
but ultimately there's an ideology
embedded in there it's not simply a
currency
and that is i think over time going to
be
what blue jeans were in the soviet union
that is to say the orange coin
is like the global symbol of freedom and
prosperity like the blue jeans were in
the soviet union
it's really a deep point you know blue
jeans in the soviet union
right were a symbol of what was there
beyond the iron curtain you know the
orange coin
is both freedom you know let's say uh
being able to transact with whoever you
want
you know to say what you want freedom
from surveillance
you know speaking your mind not being
de-platform not being censored
and of course prosperity because going
up into the right i was just thinking to
myself we're gonna have to call this
episode the four hour
the four-hour podcast that's funny
that's funny that's true
so i think that you know there's an
outside chance that india
could become a backer of crypto for
national security reasons
because it's not going to be the u.s or
china so it could play a different game
if it embraces crypto
then india gets all this from its volume
it gets all this remote pork volume and
all of its financiers
are actually quite good and all of its
engineers are also quite good the other
aspect of crypto
is it would allow indian media so this
is actually if you want a dark horse you
want a dark course prediction for the
2020s
i actually think india has the potential
to become a media superpower
why do i say that so china in the late
90s early 2000s it was making plastic
stuff for walmart
a lot of people were very skeptical of
china's ability to ascend the value
chain oh it's never going to make
you know fancy machine tools like the
germans you know etc and of course
it did it went all the way up from
iphones and stuff now it makes drones
with tgi
it makes makes basically everything
other than the very top-end
semiconductors and they're working on
china's workshop in the world and people
no longer say that it makes only crap
right it makes a lot of quality stuff
there now i'm just giving them their due
you know they do make quality stuff
and they ascended that valley chain very
intentionally very methodically with
espionage
with all kinds of with bank borrow and
steel they did everything they could
right
you have a company there they like
forced the acquisition of it oh all that
stuff they did play fair foul okay
so china became a tech and manufacturing
superpower because they've got wechat
they've got the software they've also
got the physical stuff
but i think india can take a different
path and become a tech
and media superpower and the reason i
say that is so first let me talk about
the raw material
right so of course india has bollywood
you know it has
less well-known it has the back end for
a lot of animation for hollywood
like if you go and you look at the
antenna you see all these indians there
um they did a lot of the special effects
a lot of the computer graphics because a
lot of indian engineers
and india has saja or at least a
diaspora in the u.s south asian
journalists association with like
thousands of journalists
and it has basically like this
multi-thousand-year culture of arts
letters and it's exported buddhism
and hinduism finally it's got engineers
that are competitive
worldwide right because it's now
actually number three in tech unicorns
after the us and china most people don't
know that
okay so how does india potentially
become a media superpower
well the difference is it's not just
bollywood going global
that's often the mistake people make why
because
when you go and you have a chair from
china can you tell us a chinese chair
not really it's a it's just it's a
global chair you know
you have to look on the bottom to say
ninja everything's being chopped so
there's a company for example called
arsenal matal in in
you know it's an indian company it makes
steel but it makes a global bar of seal
you can you don't look at it and be like
oh that's indian seal that's just like
globally competitive product
that's like the best product you know i
don't know i'm not a steel expert but
it's like
one of the best products for its price
right it's clearly competitive whereas
bollywood has
a specifically indian flavor to it and
this is the mind shift that i think
india is going to make in the 2020s is
going to take a lot of people by
surprise
it's going to start building products
for the world not just software products
can do that
but media products and i think the
direction is
bright sun to the west black mirror let
me explain what i mean by this
as i was saying earlier because east
coast of the us has experienced a
decline in relative status
as the internet has risen they have this
sort of black mirror world view
this future sucks meaning to crack down
their free speech and free markets
i hate these tech bros you know you
invented a bus with uber
you know like they basically are
doubling and tripling down on
the old stuff it's sort of similar to a
country where technology passes by they
double down on religious fundamentalism
well they might be pretty sure they're
not we're
better we're holier we've got a better
democracy here that kind of is coke it's
more cup
right so the west isn't the sort of
black marathon where the only thing they
can see in the future
not not all of us but certainly a lot of
the intelligentsia a lot of the media
folks and so on
one thing they can see in the future is
this black mirror right where their
future is declining
and the future is dystopian to give a
completely different world view
have you ever seen the movie or even the
trailer to super 30 i have not
okay you should definitely watch this
all your viewers should watch this
you couldn't have a more different
spirit and attitude towards technology
than this
okay like imagine sort of like
rocky but for engineers got it
kind of like that okay that's like it's
not exactly right but it's like
it's got the same spirit and it is
essentially something that just
glorifies computer science
engineering leveling up you know the
future because
here's the thing for the global south
for india you know for all these
countries that have just gotten
smartphones
they've risen with technology this is
something which is correlated with
the greatest improvement of living
standards they've ever experienced and
that
is just a completely different you can't
you can't teach that
right you can't inculcate that's just a
different cultural base the future is
looking bright we're all the way up
we're coming back to our rightful place
in the world it's kind of a mentality
there
and that is the basis for a completely
different kind of culture and
so i think that you can start the export
of
films movies culture that's based on
technology
global technology you know so all the
stuff that i talked about and
how would you do it you were like well
how do you make it not boring because
movies all require conflict right
there's going to be some pollyanna thing
right and so there's actually an
interesting flip you can do with the
dystopian movie
the key trick is it's like being a
terminator
the present is all idyllic everyone's
gambling through
the fields and so on right and then this
crazy scientist invents some horrible
you know new terminator and it messes it
all up and now the future is worse
this is a premise is that the president
was fine
and this tech guy tech bro made the
future worse right miles dyson in
terminal
but it's easy to actually invert that
when the inversion is
present that is dystopian it's a present
where we're all wearing masks it's a
present where the power is going out
it's a present where
random fires rage and cold snaps hit in
the middle of nowhere
and politics is dysfunctional oh this is
a really fictional story i'm telling
right so it's a present that's dystopian
and there's a small group that might be
able to carve out a better future right
they've just invented for example a
better form of nuclear power
but they're getting hemmed in by you
know these power hungry regulators and
these
ngos that just hate nuclear power and
press that's just trying to oppress them
for clicks and these guys need to figure
it out and actually build something
better
and so you just invert all a lot of the
troops you're still fighting the power
but you're actually fighting the power
that is technologically conservative
and you have a group of technological
progresses now that's what i just
described
actually has a lot of move to it because
that's actually reality
that is every single startup founder has
to go through what i just described
once in a while you see a hollywood
depiction of this
house of cards and netflix in its first
season actually depicted an evil ngo
like a water thing you know it was like
some water charity that was just like a
you know a scam for the uh it was the
future president's wife you know running
this thing
it depicted an evil journalist the
original ghostbusters depict an evil
regulator
so did dallas buyer's club depicted evil
regulators
so there are snatches where evil
journalists evil regulators evil ngos
are depicted
but it's like one to ten thousand or a
hundred thousand where normally it's
like the evil corporation or the evil
military that's depicted but those are
the
mental models that people slot things
into if you have media that inverts that
if you have media that allows people to
pattern recognize that and it doesn't
have to be feature films it can be
short video games it can be clips and so
on that's actually upstream of driving
technological progress
because it shows the technology is good
b it still has
conflict as much conflict as a dystopian
and see
you can just take all these plots adapt
them straight from the history of a
thousand different
tech companies startups and then going
backwards further in time
you know robert goddard had to fight nyt
co
you know for on rockets and do you know
that story but basically they said that
it was a total joke that what he was
doing was a joke they were
basically being technologically
conservative forever so every innovators
had to fight this
and those stories are on the shelf that
we can just take off and make into
things
right all right let me pause well there
just going to say dark horses
and cryptocurrencies and balaji oh my
this episode is going to take
my team a hundred years maybe i'll need
a thousand indians to help us with this
to do the show notes i'm just imagining
linking to everything that that we that
we
i'm using the royal we here that you
have discussed so far
so i think this makes a lot of sense
in part because my headset is running
out of battery
and my bloodstream is running out of
glucose i think this is probably a good
chapter one for folks
but is there is there anything that you
would like to say
if you're open to to closing now or
close
to it are there any closing
you'll also be able to get some crypto
tasks if you like this there's a lot
more of it and it's all better organized
in writing
um tim has been a very gracious host
been a lot of fun
and uh you know i think um all these
ideas are laid out at greater length in
the book and on
the tasks on the website it's all free
wonderful and people can find you on
twitter
at biology s website biology s
dot com for everybody listening my team
will make a best
effort to link to everything that we
have discussed it is going to be
it is going to be an incredibly
voluminous
version of show notes and baloney thank
you so much for
taking the time this is going to have to
be the episode of everything there are
many titles that are vying
for the final version of what we will
call this episode it'll be very very
challenging but i'm looking forward to
it as a challenge
but thank you for making the time this
has been great we've covered a lot of
ground
awesome thank you hey guys this is tim
again just a few more things before you
take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the uh the world of the esoteric this
podcast episode
articles sleep is super important to me
here's my close friend
for
all sorts of different mattresses
i also have one in the guest bedroom and
feedback from friends has always been
fantastic it's something that they
comment on helix sleep
has a quiz it takes about two minutes to
complete that matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helix sleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up from
you if you don't love it and now my dear
listeners helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance i recommended it in fact in
the four-hour body this is more than 10
years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75
vitamins minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients you'd be very
hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense and comprehensive formula
on the market it has multi-vitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i focus on nutrient-dense meals
to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer
on top of their all-in-one formula which
is a free vitamin d supplement
and five free travel packs with your
first subscription
purchase many of us are deficient in
vitamin d i found that true for myself
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine is a
great option for additional immune
support support your immunity
gut health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
subscription again that's
[Music]
athleticgreens.com
you